Welcome to the podcast.
Gird your loins, people,
because today we're gonna dive deep
into how to absolutely kick ass
and take names as a plant-based athlete.
From strength to endurance,
fueling to recovery,
macronutrients to micronutrients,
we're gonna lay it all out,
we're gonna bust a few myths,
we're gonna answer some common questions,
including, of course, the big one,
where do you get your protein?
And my guests for this adventure
are my friends Matt Frazier and Robert Cheeke.
Together, they co-authored this fantastic new book,
"The Plant-Based Athlete,"
which is essentially the ultimate guide
to maxing out peak performance the plant-based way,
which is a drum I think you guys know at this point,
I have been beating for many, many years.
If you're a day one fan,
then you remember Matt
from way back on the show, Episode 54.
He's a plant-based marathoner, ultra runner,
and the man behind the nomeatathlete.com,
community, books and podcast.
Robert is a former champion vegan bodybuilder,
public speaker.
He's the Founder of Vegan Bodybuilding & Fitness,
and just a super solid dude
who's been absolutely crushing it on nothing but plants
for more than 25 years.
This is a fun, super informative, plant-fueled mind meld
that I have no doubt will leave you empowered
to upgrade your daily plate and crushing your fitness goals.
So, please hit that subscribe button, and here we go.
This is me, Matt Frazier and Robert Cheeke.
(upbeat music)
(Robert laughing)
He's like ready to pounce.
Are we rolling?
We are rolling.
We're good.
The OG plant-based crew is in the house,
good to see you guys.
Thanks for having us, Rich.
Yeah, you too, Rich.
It's good to be reconnected with both of you.
It's been a little while, and all of us go back pretty far.
Yeah, at least a decade or probably some years, maybe.
I know, I'm trying to remember the first time
that I met each of you guys.
I'm sure it was at some veg fest related event,
perhaps a decade or so ago.
I remember Matt,
the first time you did the podcast, we were in DC.
That's right, at the DC VegFest.
Right, in a hotel room.
Yep.
Like at the DC VegFest,
which I think Robert, you mentioned that you first met Matt
in DC also?
Yeah.
Was that at the same event?
I was speaking at the DC VegFest.
It was a year or two before that.
Oh, it was.
Yeah.
But you guys go way back as well.
We do.
I've been just wrapping my head around
having you guys back on
has taken me down a little bit of a memory lane
and I was just remembering the early days.
Robert, you've been doing this for 25 years.
You've been doing it for, Matt--
12.
12 at this point.
I'm at 15, and I was just remembering in the early days,
thinking about who the mentors were,
what the landscape looked like,
where the resources could be found.
And it was basically Brendan Brazier's book "Thrive,"
it was his Vega products
that I had to drive all the way to Erewhon
in the middle of...
There was one store in all of Los Angeles that sold it
and I would drive all the way across town
like an hour and a half to get it.
And then shortly thereafter,
Matt, you launched your blog No Meat Athlete.
How long ago was that?
When did that first?
That was 2009.
2009, right?
Yep.
And Robert, you had veganbodybuilding.com way back.
Yeah, we went live February 2003.
Wow.
But I was making T-shirts back in 2002.
Yeah, you're the original DIY
vegan plant-based athlete dude
who's been banging the drum for longer than most.
Man, it's been such a DIY thing.
Doing things I didn't know what I was doing,
making T-shirts, self-publishing books.
I was just telling Matt on the way here,
I put myself on a college campus speaking tour
and was just trying to find my way around to the buildings
to get to the right place.
Sometimes speaking in front of five people
that I would spend $700 out of pocket to be there.
Yeah, you're the guy who come out to the parking lot,
and let me pop the trunk open
and I got all kinds of swag for you.
I was.
We've all been that guy.
Rip Esselstyn had me speak
at the whole Whole Foods Market headquarters
in 2010, I believe.
My book had just come out
and, yeah, I was traveling in my Prius
and just sleeping in my car
unless I had a friend to crash with
and that's what I was trying to do
just to get off the ground.
Right, well, a lot has changed.
(chuckles)
A lot has changed.
In the last year.
We're in a very different moment
and I suspect both of you are gratified by the cultural tilt
in the direction of things that you guys care about
and have been talking about for a long time.
Yeah, absolutely.
It's so, so different
to be plant-based athlete these days
than even five or 10 years ago, just so different.
Yeah.
In many good ways.
It's also a lot easier to get the junk food.
It doesn't mean quite the same thing to be vegan anymore,
but, yeah, it's reaching so many more people.
Yeah, that's crazy.
So, we're very grateful.
And that's the right word, Rich, is grateful.
We have that gratitude.
We were believing in something a long time ago,
hoping that it would take off,
hoping that it would strike a chord with people,
hoping people would embrace it
and obviously people like you and others
have given us a bigger platform.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
I want this to be really instructive for the audience
with a lot of kind of tactics and strategies
that will be helpful to people
that are all lifted from your amazing new book,
which we're gonna get into
but I think it would be good
to just introduce yourselves a little bit.
I wanna spend a couple minutes
on each of your respective backgrounds
'cause I think that helps contextualize everything
that we're gonna talk about.
So, Robert, we can start with you.
I know you grew up on, basically, a farm in Oregon, right?
And at a very early age made this shift.
Yeah, I grew up on a farm in Western Oregon, Corvallis,
Oregon State University town.
My father was a professor at Oregon State University.
That's where he met my mother.
He taught animal agriculture, right?
Yeah, animal science.
He actually is or was at the time, he's retired now,
but is a world expert on raising animals for food.
So, when I was a young kid,
he traveled to every continent except for Antarctica.
He wrote 15 textbooks for college students
about raising animals, particularly raising rabbits.
And so, he would travel around--
Raising rabbits for food?
Yeah, so, he would go around
to different countries around the world
teaching various students or cultures
about the efficiency of raising rabbit meat.
He even won a rabbit Oscar in the '80's, I think,
as a top rabbit researcher in the world
and wrote a bunch of textbooks.
And that's the background that I came from.
I used to raise rabbits
and I would show them in the 4-H County Fair
and sell them at the auction
and I did that with dairy cows, with chickens.
And I came from this farming background
and not only that but that animal science background,
where both of my parents were animal scientists
and were very concerned that in 1995 when I became vegan
really out of respect for my older sister,
who was organizing an animal rights week at our high school,
that I wasn't gonna get enough, proper nutrition.
This was slightly before the internet, 1995,
or weeks before the public internet.
There was a lot of fear
that you're just not gonna get enough protein
and you're gonna be malnourished on top of that.
I think you know part of my story.
When I was in eighth grade, I weighed 89 pounds.
I was up to the massive 120
by the time I was a sophomore in high school
and became vegan.
I was a small guy.
Right.
I was an endurance athlete.
Well, (chuckles) let's hold on.
I wanna back up a little bit.
So, do you have other siblings besides your sister?
Yeah.
You do.
Yeah, so my older sister, Tanya,
became vegan vegetarian at a young age.
Maybe she was eight or 10 or something.
And then my younger brother, Ryan,
was always the cowboy guy, always the farmer.
Driving the big truck, gun rack on his pickup truck,
bumper sticker is like "Enjoy a juicy steak tonight,"
"Cowboys do it in eight seconds," all this stuff.
And then my youngest brother, Clark,
who was 11 at the time became vegetarian
when I became vegan in December of '95.
So, three of the kids in your family go vegetarian vegan.
And this is a classic teenage rebellion
against the ideals of the parents.
Your parents must have lost their minds.
Everybody lost their minds.
Can you imagine the holidays?
And my sister was especially outspoken.
We would go to protests.
We were involved in animal rights.
Right, like Food Not Bombs.
Exactly, we ran Food Not Bombs.
(laughs excitedly)
We ran Food Not Bombs in Corvallis.
I was making soup for people in need
or anyone who was hungry
and serving it in central park in my town for years.
So, rejecting the rabbit stew at dinner.
Yeah, but also being 15
and not knowing exactly what to eat
and not having these resources, like you mentioned,
Brendan Brazier and others, they weren't there.
John Robbins had a book,
there are a few other resources.
Howard Lyman was big back then,
but as an athlete--
Peter Singer.
Yeah, but as an athlete, it was man--
Nothing.
What do I do?
And I was a five sport athlete in high school
and had aspirations of doing something well after that.
Right, so, it's basically a lot of tofu sandwiches--
A lot of tofu.
I even tried to get sponsored by a tofu company back before.
I collected every package and saved them in my closet,
which I know it sounds weird,
but every package of tofu hotdogs and bologna and all that
from Yves Veggie Cuisine
and I saved hundreds of packages
and took photos and tried to get sponsored.
It never worked out.
And you started as a runner
and then didn't get into...
Did you run at OSU?
One year, yeah, at Oregon State University.
It was a running club,
not to be confused with University of Oregon
for people listening, the mega successful athletic program
but we had a running club back then.
Now it's a full-on track and cross country team
but back in the '90s, '98 or '99, I ran there.
So, when did the bodybuilding thing kick off for you?
Right after that.
Late '99, I bumped
into an old childhood friend, Jordan Baskerville,
who was still one of my absolute best friends today
and he introduced me to the sport of bodybuilding,
a sport I didn't know about.
In fact, I was kind of grossed out by those magazines
that I would see at the grocery store
with all the veins and muscles on the cover
but he showed me those magazines
and at this point I was ready to be bigger and stronger,
something I had never been
and wanted to be like Captain Planet,
wanted to be like He-Man,
wanted to be pro wrestler.
And so, I embraced it.
And then I did the Body for Life program in 2000
and it took off from there.
Right, so, 2000,
basically like from 2000 through around 2009,
you got into a competition 2006, 2009.
Those were kind of big years for you
in terms of distinguishing yourself and winning
and you won the...
What is it?
The USA Natural Bodybuilding competition?
Yeah, there's all these federations.
This is the INBA,
International Natural
Bodybuilding Association
It's confusing.
There's a lot of, yeah.
It's not one thing.
Yeah, There's a bunch of federations,
but yeah, I won, I think it's the INBA Northwestern USA
Natural Bodybuilding Championships in my category
and there's lots of different categories too, right?
But that gave me something to talk about,
because it wasn't just I was always a bodybuilder.
I was a small, long distance runner and vegan on top of that
and then found some success in bodybuilding,
won a couple of competitions,
runner up a number of times.
There was interest then from magazines,
newspapers, the internet
and I was able to build a culture around that.
Right, and you've really stepped into this role
of advocacy and kind of shouldered the responsibility
of trying to communicate this, what, in your case
and all of our cases together here collectively
has been a transformative lifestyle experience.
Yeah, and it's something I always wanted.
When I decided that on that December 8th day in '95,
I thought, man, if I could get bigger and stronger
without any animal protein,
that could inspire other people to believe in themselves
that they could do it too.
And there were other high school classmates that did it.
People on my track team, people on my soccer team,
they did it, both men and women.
They embraced it, at least for a period of time,
and we had something building there
and then it just continued to pick up
where you'd meet someone else
who was a plant-based athlete.
We didn't call it plant-based back then
but another vegan athlete.
You'd meet someone
and it was like, okay, this is really starting
to take off a little bit.
Right.
Maybe there's something to this.
There's something here.
Yeah, fast forward to game changers
and everything that's unfolded in the heck of it.
So, it's cool.
Matt, when I think of you,
I think what's powerful about your story and your message,
and obviously I wanna hear from you,
is that you are a very kind of relatable person.
You're somebody who's kind of a middle of the pack runner,
who just went on his own journey
of trying to optimize your own performance in your own way.
I think when I first met you,
you weren't even fully plant-based.
You were vegetarian, I think.
That's possible
'cause when I started,
there were fish recipes
in the very early days of No Meat Athlete
'cause I was like fish doesn't really count as meat.
I'll just call this No Meat Athlete
and I was thinking I might become vegetarian.
Didn't know what vegan was just thought.
So, I started with fish
and it didn't even occur to me
that that might make some people really angry,
and I mean now having done the internet for 12 years,
I know that sounds crazy.
How dare you change your mind and evolve?
Yeah, (chuckles) right, I know.
But yeah, I was vegetarian
for, I think, the first two years of doing my blog
and people like you,
people like Brendan Brazier, people like Robert,
just the exposure to these ideas,
that's what moved me towards veganism.
And really it was the ethical side of it
but seeing you guys do it, that's what made it.
And you started nomeatathlete.com
in kind of the heyday of blogging, right?
When blogging was like,
that's where we were all gonna various blogs
to get our information.
Still to this day, you've continued to do this
and grow this amazing community that you have.
And I like how kind of authentic and transparent you are
about this journey with respect to running
and how you continue to kind of iterate and evolve and learn
when it comes to nutrition.
Yeah, I think that you're right.
That's what people have been attracted to about the site.
I was never an elite athlete by any means.
In those early days,
I was searching for help
in qualifying for the Boston Marathon,
which when I started out,
I would say I was middle of the pack
and that was for me elite level accomplishment,
which was a lot.
Tons of people qualified for Boston,
but it took a ton of work for me to get there
and the last bit was when I did find that go vegetarian.
It was like six months after that
is when I finally qualified
even though I didn't go vegetarian for that.
I was going for ethical reasons.
And then in my search on the internet,
thinking, okay, if I really wanna do this,
and that's why I was eating fish too,
'cause I was worried about protein.
What I need to be making sure I'm eating right
and I kinda started looking around
and I must've found Robert's site,
but I didn't find anything for endurance athletes.
I missed the whole Brendan Brazier stuff
because he didn't have a blog or anything
that was easily find-able.
So, I said, well man, there's nothing here
for people who wanna be vegetarian athletes.
So, I'll just start writing about what I'm doing.
Not that I have any expertise.
I'm just gonna share what's working and what isn't
and how it's going.
And that really has been what No Meat Athlete state.
That's still what I do,
is just write about what I'm doing
or what our team is doing,
'cause I'm a little bit less involved
in the day-to-day writing.
Yeah, now you have
a huge team.
(chuckles)
I wouldn't say huge.
I think we've got--
I don't know.
On the site it looked like there were 12 people.
Yeah, 'cause we launched a supplement company
called Compliment a few years after that
and that company has grown much faster
than No Meat Athlete actually did
in terms of hiring team members and all that.
So, we've got a bunch there.
So, your first stab at the Boston Marathon,
you ran like 4:30 plus or something like that.
My very first marathon,
I had no idea that I had no business
even thinking about qualifying for Boston,
but I wrote that down as my target finish time
on the application or whatever.
I wrote down 3:10 and I finished in 4:53.
So, I was a hundred minutes too slow.
(laughs heartily)
Over an hour and a half drop.
There's a big improvement arc here to happen,
but you switched up your diet.
I'm sure there were other factors.
Oh, that was just the last bit.
But then the next stab you end up qualifying.
I think you qualified by one second?
(chuckles)
You just got in under the nose.
Is that right?
So, the story has gotten better and better.
It's one of those stories about--
This is a (mumbles).
Right.
Yeah.
So, it was six stabs later that I finally did it.
Wow.
I took off an hour the first time
because I learned to have that proper training
and not get hurt
and then I learned how to actually run with efficient form
and then I learned about nutrition.
Each kept getting better.
So, 3:10 was a time that was in my head all those years.
And I was big individualization goal setting.
I wrote that down so many times in journals
that I was gonna run a 3:10 marathon
and I ended up crossing the line in 3:09:59.
So, it sounds like I did it by one second and I did,
but it turns out
that they gave you then a minute grace period.
So, 3:10:59 would've done it.
So, I qualified by a minute.
It's a better story.
It's so much better.
(laughs)
And I like how you were mentored
by Seth Godin on your blog,
which is that's rare era.
How did you make it happen?
Yeah, I was extremely lucky to get that.
I just followed everything he did.
I read every book he wrote
and just loved what he was doing
'cause he was doing marketing but making it not feel sleazy.
And honestly, when I went vegetarian,
I was afraid of it being this cultish thing,
where people were always trying to convince you
and trying to make you feel wrong for not eating the way,
not seeing things the way they did.
And so, I was terrified of that,
of being that, portraying that.
And so, when I did,
I said I'm just gonna kind of
be the most chill vegetarian I can be.
I'm not gonna tell anyone they should do this.
I'm just gonna say, "Hey, it's working for me.
"If you wanna try it, here are some tools."
So, Seth Godin has that exact same approach
to me to marketing,
where it doesn't feel like you're being sold.
It just feels like someone's
a lot of fun to listen to and learn from.
So, I think my vibe very much resonated with his
and he announced that he was gonna have 15 readers
come spend a week in his office and work on projects
and I applied and I figured
I'm not actually gonna get this,
but I did a little video
and he had written the blurb for my first book.
He'd written a nice little thing
because I had heard
he was mostly vegetarian or vegan or something back then.
Yeah, and then somehow he picked me.
It's great.
Which is fine 'cause he tells you
it's about picking yourself.
You don't wanna be picked, but I got picked.
So, what is that like?
Did you go to his house?
Yeah.
Yeah?
I went to his office,
which was really cool.
He really could trust.
Yeah, and in fact, your place here
reminds me a lot of his office
with the books all over the wall
and little trinkets and things, but yeah.
I got to go to his house
and he made pizza.
No, I forget.
He had a pizza oven in the backyard that he showed us,
but we had a little party
and oh, it was just surreal for me.
Right, that's cool.
Yeah.
So, both of you guys have written books before.
Robert, I think, were all your books
prior to this one self published
out of the trunk of the car?
Every single one.
I've written four.
I wrote four before this one.
(laughs)
And Matt you've got "No Meat Athlete"
and the "No Meat Athlete Cookbook,"
but this new book,
you guys crushed it with this thing.
There's so many things about this book that I love
and I think that are important
and we're missing in the conversation
around being plant-based
and specifically how to be a plant-based athlete.
Robert, I heard you talking the other day
about something that I think is very true,
which is that historically most of the books
about being plant-based as an athlete
have been memoir style books,
like my books, right?
Exactly.
They're kind of anecdotal, first person accounts
of a certain kind of transformation
and those have their place,
but the idea behind your book,
which I think is fantastic is that you guys said,
we wanna make basically the Bible,
the manual for how to do this
irrespective of what your particular sport is
and we're gonna do that by laying out the latest science
and telling the stories of tons of athletes,
I think 25 athletes throughout the book,
and their various versions of how they make it work.
And I think together that coheres
to create a really powerful volume
that anybody who's flirting with the idea
of stepping into this world
is gonna find value in.
Yeah, thanks, Rich
and Matt jokes that it's kind of a grownup version
of our other books.
This is the real deal.
You guys are adults now.
Yeah, we're adults now.
It's a phase where we're in our 40's now.
Robert's still getting used
to not having to open up his trunk.
(laughs)
I still do it.
You mean a publisher will send it directly to the person?
Yeah, I rolled up here at your office
with five books in the trunk, actually in the backseat
so I wouldn't forget them.
And yeah, I wasn't even sure
that the publisher (laughs) sent you a copy.
I'm used to doing this stuff myself.
But what we wanted to do was make the how to book.
This is the how to book for anybody
to be a plant-based athlete.
And we feature so many different men and women in the book.
Like you said, it's not just your way
or Brendan Brazier's way
or Scott Jurek's way or Matt's way or my way
or Fiona's way.
It's this culmination of all these different approaches
that are really unique to the individuals.
There's not necessarily one size fits all,
but the fact that there's some very specific aspects
that are similar,
such as the omission of animal protein,
the inclusion of exclusively plant-based foods
and this unbelievable belief in self to achieve something.
And that ties all of these people together.
They may eat a bit differently.
And how could you not?
You talk about someone like Meagan Duhamel,
who's an Olympic gold medalist plant-based figure skater.
She's gonna eat a little bit differently
than David Carter, who was in the NFL as a lineman,
a 300 pound lineman.
And I think that needs to be shared.
So, we have all of these different athletes
and Matt comes from an endurance background, of course,
and I come from most of the strength
and bodybuilding background
and that's where our respective audiences kind of hang out
in Vegan Bodybuilding and No Meat Athlete,
but this encompasses everyone.
And so, there's a story for you to resonate with as a reader
and what was fun for me.
And actually it's not just 25 stories.
I personally interviewed about 60 people for the book
and some just have quotes in there.
Their stories didn't get developed as further,
but their quotes are in there
and they're mentioned
and they're referenced
and they're world champions and Olympic medalists
and the best in the world in some cases of what they do.
And that is there as a source of inspiration.
That you can find someone to connect with.
And it's interesting who we connect with.
I connect well with someone like Sonya Looney,
for example, world champion, mountain biker.
I've never been on a mountain bike before,
but her just mental toughness, intestinal fortitude,
her grit as she calls it,
it speaks to me
as someone who has been on the grind as well.
(laughs)
Like we said, going out in my car
to try to make this dream happen.
It just speaks to me
that today I'm gonna be the best version of myself.
She has that story.
Right.
And the stories of,
I'm in my 40's now.
Your story, Scott Jurek, John Joseph, Rip Esselstyn,
Fiona Oakes, Christine Vardaros, those speak to me too.
These are individuals, yourself included,
who are in often cases reaching their athletic peak
in their 40's, or even in some cases 50's.
Rip just set a world record in 200 meter backstroke
at what 58, 59 masters?
Yeah, he's killing in Masters Records.
That's amazing.
That gives me a lot of inspiration
as someone who retired
from competitive bodybuilding at age 29
and has been training for the last 10 years
and I've been the biggest and strongest I've ever been
at age 40, age 41.
Man, I still got a lot left.
That's what it tells me as a reader.
In the course of speaking to these 60 odd athletes
and hearing their stories
and creating these profiles for the book,
I suspect you were exposed to a pretty wide variety
of experiences, right?
Obviously, people are gonna eat differently
depending upon their specialty.
Their habits are gonna be different,
and I'm sure there's tons of consistencies, right,
in the various approaches.
Was there anything that surprised you?
(chuckles)
Yes, I conducted the interviews so I can speak to this.
What really surprised me
was that we have this Day In the Life section in the book
and the fact that some of the best athletes in the world
includes something like Ben & Jerry's ice cream
into their diet.
And that just really blew me away.
I was hanging out in the early days with Brendan Brazier,
who wanted to eat vegan ice cream
and it was all about
every calorie has gotta be aimed towards performance,
but to realize that some of the best athletes in the world,
with their hair down,
they do things like they eat Beyond Burgers,
they eat non-dairy ice cream.
Robbie Balenger's tour was sponsored by NadaMoo
and his story of running across America
is one of my favorites in the book
and one of my favorites to write.
I just love that story.
So, that surprised me a little bit,
because I grew up in this...
I worked for Forks Over Knives
and I took Dr. Campbell's plant-based nutrition course
through Cornell
and I hang out in the vegan cruise,
where you and I did that speaking panel
in the very early days of your podcast.
Well, what happened there?
I wanted to highlight that.
We took a stab at trying to do a podcast
right back in the day
when we were on that vegan cruise thing.
And what happened is what has happened many,
I don't know if you remember how frustrated I was.
I remember 'cause I was sitting there by myself
wondering where is Rich?
There's hundreds of people in the audience
and just you and I on the speaking panel,
just the two of us,
and where is Rich?
And you were trying to come with all your equipment
to record it.
Basically, what happens
is whenever I have like a live,
we were doing this kind of live Q&A panel type thing
in front of a group of people
and I always go to the event organizer ahead of time
and say, "I wanna record this.
"This might be good for the podcast."
And they're like "Oh, no problem.
"No, it's totally easy.
"We'll just plug it into our soundboard."
And I used to take people at face value
and they didn't tell me that.
What I've learned that when they say that,
they actually have no idea what they're talking about
and I have zero confidence it's gonna actually work.
But in this case they were like,
"No, we have it wired.
"We're gonna do that.
"We're gonna do,'
and we did the whole thing.
I'm like none of it recorded.
(chuckles)
Yeah, and it was a great conversation.
I know it was like, I don't know, eight years ago.
Yeah, seven.
It was a long time ago.
It was, yeah, probably seven years ago.
Yeah, it was a long time ago,
but I remember because that was a bit nerve wracking for me.
You were really ascending
as one of the big plant-based athletes
and just the two of us.
There was nowhere to hide
(chuckles)
and I felt like, man, I held my own out there.
I felt good about that.
Come on.
You've been doing this way longer than me.
You know more about...
I'm here to learn from you guys today.
Right, but that's how I felt.
And it was honor and it was fun
and I thought, wow, that's my early opportunity
to be on the Rich Roll Podcast.
Here am--
Seven years later, here we are.
Yeah, here we are.
We made it happen.
(laughs)
What was I asking you though?
I lost my track there.
We were talking about the similarities
of the people interviewed.
Oh, right, yeah.
And so, I came from that background of Forks Over Knives
and T. Colin Campbell,
great role models for me, heroes of mine.
It's such an honor to have endorsement for the book,
but I felt that level of perfection was necessary
and I live that way
and I wrote myself published book, "Shred It,"
that it was no processed foods,
no sports supplements, none of that.
And what I found later was that I was trying so hard
to please other people because their name was on the book
or I viewed them as my heroes
and I wanted to live just the way that they described.
But then now that I've been on this vegan cruise
10 years in a row,
I would see people like Dr. T. Colin Campbell
eating vegan pizza at midnight.
I'm like, oh, there's room for that.
I didn't understand that
because we always put our best foot forward,
our best information forward
in written form and in videos and interviews
and sometimes that's a hard thing to maintain
and a hard thing to achieve.
So, for me telling these compelling stories,
it was really enlightening
for me to see that people who are way better athletes
than I've ever been in my life
allow downtime for some processed foods,
what you call junk food.
Right, just not being wed
to some super strict unrealistic protocol
that's just not gonna work over time.
It's always been a thing for me
to figure out how to square
that traditional T. Colin Campbell,
Caldwell Esselstyn message
of not only zero processed food,
but very, very little fat
and I've just not figured over the years of being an athlete
that I need not need more fat in my diet
in order to perform and recover and all of those things
and feeling myself guilty
that I couldn't get completely on board
with that strict protocol.
Yeah, and I thought it was important
that we shared that message in this book
because some of my other books
or other people's books in this space
have been very specific about a program.
You need to eat this certain way.
And I realized you don't,
and there's lots of different versions of a plant-based diet
that work completely differently
for the California State record holder
in powerlifting, Nick Squires.
Nick Squires is always on Twitter talking about
how many Beyond Meat Burgers he's eaten--
Meek is hilarious
by the way.
He puts it away like crazy.
Yeah, and, well, listen,
you gotta follow that guy on Twitter.
He's just hilarious.
In his weight class, he's strongest person
in the State of California,
which has nearly 40 million people living here
and he's been plant-based and ethical vegan for a long time
and he's incredible.
And I think we have to recognize that.
We have to recognize
that there's so many different ways to do this
and by showing that day in the life routine
from morning till night,
that so many athletes shared in the book,
that was even a wake-up call for me
as someone who's been doing this for a quarter century.
These are way better athletes than I've ever been
and they allow this kind of flexibility
that is important that for all of us as readers
to recognize that that's the truth.
Really, that's the reality.
Right.
It goes back with Esselstyn and Campbell.
It goes back to this fact that
this movement is new enough still
that there's still
a relatively limited amount of resources about it.
It's growing so fast now,
but over the past 15 years,
it's been a handful of books
that have really influenced things.
So, I think there's this sense
that whichever one you just read,
that's the one way to do it.
So, even with those guys
who are Mount Olympus of this vegan plant-based movement--
But are also focused on preventing heart attacks.
Right.
They're not focused on performance as an athlete.
Right, and so there are one way is,
is there a particular way of preventing long-term disease?
But there are even other ways of doing that.
There are Joel Kahn, Michael Greger,
they don't have quite the same approach
as those guys do with the low fat.
Or McDougall and Fuhrman,
who were at odds in a lot of ways,
but both produce great results--
In fighting.
(laughs)
But I think that's--
A lot in fighting.
As the movement grows as does that.
Everybody has contributed to this movement,
but I think the idea that this one way
is the right way to do this.
I think that's a disservice
because it makes it seem like this diet must be hard.
You must have to be really careful
if you're gonna be plant-based.
You have to be this specific and do these specific things.
The number of athlete accounts in this book
show is that that's not really true.
There are so many ways to do this
because it's a versatile diet.
It's not something that you have to exactly get right.
There are a few little nutrients you need to probably need
to make sure you get,
but you don't need to be more careful doing this than you do
if you eat McDonald's all the time.
I'd be more careful on a diet
that involves lots of that food than one like ours.
(air whooshes)
Right, sorry to interrupt the flow.
We'll be right back with more awesome
but I wanna snack a moment
to talk to you about the importance of nutrition.
The thing is most people I know
actually already know how to eat better
and aspire to incorporate more whole plants.
More fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans, and lagoons
into their daily routine.
Sadly, however, without the kitchen tools and support,
very few end up sticking with it.
So, because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly
and because I want everybody to experience
some version of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised, I'm proud to say,
is the PlantPower Meal Planner,
our affordable, all-in-one digital platform
that sets you up for nutrition excellence
by providing access to thousands of highly customizable,
super delicious and easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery
and you get access to our amazing team of nutrition coaches
seven days a week
and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up,
visit meals.richroll.com
and right now for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off an annual membership
when you use the promo code, RRHEALTH at checkout.
This is life-changing stuff people
for just $1.70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com,
promo code, RRHEALTH for $10 off an annual membership.
All right,
Let's get back to the show.
(air whooshing)
So, why don't we walk through, in practical terms,
how one who is thinking about perhaps jumping into this,
how one would do it.
When we talk about being plant-based or vegan,
by definition, all that says
is that we're not eating animal products
and it says nothing about what we are eating.
And bearing in mind
that this can look different ways for different individuals,
how do you speak to that person
who's tuning in right now,
who's just saying, tell me how to do it,
or is under the impression
that it is unbelievably restrictive
and it's gonna require all this time and this prep.
We can do a little bit of myth-busting along the way.
(chuckles)
Yeah, I think it's important to acknowledge
what your favorite plant-based foods are, to begin with.
What are your five favorite fruits,
vegetables, legumes, grains--
French fries.
Nuts and seeds.
(laughs)
Start there really.
It's okay.
It's a question worth answering,
I think for each person,
because then you'll recognize,
oh, yeah, I really do like all these burrito bowls and tacos
and these different types of international cuisines
that are largely rice, vegetables, tofu, curries,
whatever the case is
and realize, oh yeah,
I like all these different summer fruits
and I like all this.
I like potatoes and I like rice
and I like all these things
that are staples in a healthy plant-based diet
that you're eating all the time
without necessarily recognizing it.
Or tastes almost exactly the same
if you just pull the beef broth out of it
or the meat component of it.
Yeah, and also recognize
that a lot of people who do eat animals
tend to eat the same four of them all the time.
They eat cows, chickens, pigs and what?
Fish, I guess, maybe.
There's not a lot of variety there.
Variety is often the broccoli, the green beans,
the cauliflower, the beans, the wild rice,
the salad greens, the seasonings,
the herbs and spices, the condiments
that are all plant-based.
And so, just find those staple foods
that you really do enjoy.
It doesn't mean you have to eat tofu all day long.
It doesn't mean you have eat a certain thing.
So, what do you have for breakfast?
Maybe oatmeal or cereal?
Easy, plant-based, right?
And then add a little to it.
Put some berries on there.
Put some walnuts on there.
Get those omega three essential fats.
Get the antioxidants from the dark pigment fruits.
Add more calories to it.
More oomph, more, more power for the day
or your green smoothie.
Just do it without any whey protein
or casein protein or non-dairy yogurts,
or, like I said, cereals or fruit platters.
There's breakfast.
And then explore foods like potatoes
and yams and sweet potatoes and lentils and beans and rice,
and some of these heavy 500 calorie per pound,
more calorie dense legumes and grains
and root vegetables for lunch
or things that you already eat.
Sandwiches, wraps, burgers.
Find a plant-based version.
They're everywhere and anywhere in America now.
So, it's making those changes
that you don't feel any deprivation.
You don't feel like it's a chore or a hassle.
It's like these are the foods I already like.
I'm just having a plant-based burger now
or plant-based pizza.
Matt and I had pizza last night when we rolled into town
and these are available now for people.
So, I think it's finding the foods that you already like
and then I think there's a necessary understanding
of calorie density and nutrient density,
at least as far as getting the most mileage
from your plant-based diet.
Yeah, because that's one of the things
that I hear often.
I'm sure you do as well.
I tried this but I was hungry all the time.
I'm like, you're not eating enough.
Or frequently enough in many cases.
Well, can I tell you a scenario?
Sure.
So, this is--
This is what you're here to do, Robert.
Tell me the scenario.
So, this is so common.
I've watched this over the last 25 years
and people often come to me in conversation or email
with this topic.
So, let's say you're a male athlete,
'cause I interact with a lot of them
through the bodybuilding sphere.
So, they're consuming, let's say, 3,000 calories
on an omnivorous diet, right?
And they switched to an all plant-based diet
and now they're down to maybe consuming
2,000 calories or 2,200 calories.
And they're like, man, I've lost some weight.
My energy has gone down.
I'm not as strong.
You just cut out a third of your calorie intake
without being aware of it until now,
until once we evaluate it.
And this happens all the time
because the calorie density
of meat and animal protein is so high
and it also comes packaged oftentimes with lots of oil
and other cheese or dairy products
or sour cream or whatever, eggs,
where you're getting a much higher calorie intake.
And so, if you're a football player, a bodybuilder,
a weightlifter or a basketball player,
really active in any kind of sport
and you significantly reduce your calorie intake
because you're eating salads
and fruits and vegetables
and you're just omitting animal protein
without an awareness of calorie density,
of course, you're gonna have lower energy.
Energy is from our calorie intake.
Of course, you're gonna lose some weight
because you can't mathematically maintain that mass
in a calorie deficit, in reduction
and that happens all the time.
Yeah, the thing is,
is that you don't realize
that you're running a caloric deficit
compared to the way that you used to be eating
because if you amp up the fiber in your diet,
you get full,
you'll feel full--
And it happens all the time.
And so, you think that you're eating
as much as you were before
when in fact you're eating quite a bit less.
Which is, that's why I said frequently,
because you think you're gonna try
to eat a whole lot at a meal
to make up for the fact
that your food doesn't have as many calories, but can't.
You get full and you feel like you've eaten just as much.
So, the trick for me
when I'm trying to put weight on or keep weight on
is just eat more often
just as much as I can.
Not at any one meal, but just throughout the day.
Let's talk about a little bit about the why.
We probably should've started with this.
Why is this something that people should be thinking about?
Why is this a better way to go?
Weren't we born and bred to be omnivorous?
What's so terrible
about eating a moderate and healthy omnivorous diet?
Yeah, I think a number of things problematic with that.
One is that that's a diet lifestyle
that contributes to higher cases mortality across the board.
A plant-based diet is, as Gregory says,
it should be the default diet until proven otherwise,
because it can reduce the risk of all-cause mortality.
For me, I got into this
literally having dairy cows as friends, as Pat says.
How do so many people in the plant-based movement
are people who grew up on farm?
(laughs)
Like Dr. Klaper--
Well, there's something to that
because you look at animals differently.
How you would treat your dogs,
we just extend that to chickens,
because think about this, Rich.
I grew up on a farm where you raised animals
from when they're babies
and if they're taken from their mothers,
who is their new best friend, it's you?
I used to bottle feed baby calves
before getting on the school bus.
I used to hang out with baby chicks
and play a little elevator game with my hand.
They trust you.
You are their person just like for your dog.
You are that person.
So, I think for me,
I just looked at animals differently
and that was something that
even if I thought I might have diminished returns
on athletic success adopting this lifestyle,
I was willing to do it
because it just spoke to me.
And that's what compelled me
all these years later for 25 years.
Luckily, it didn't have a hindrance.
It didn't have any adverse effects
on my athletic performance.
In fact, maybe helped it,
but that's certainly one of the reasons,
is allowing animals to live lives
free of fear, pain, and suffering
and I think that's valid.
I think that's worth considering.
We can talk about all the environmental factors
and I don't even know a lot of those nuances.
I'm not a scientist.
I don't understand all the greenhouse gas stuff.
I see the quotes and how many gallons of water are used
just to raise animals and all of that.
Of course, it's important to me,
but I can't really speak to that necessarily.
I can speak to my cause or my why
and I can speak to the fact that so many people,
even if it's anecdotal,
the stuff that I've seen for 25 years,
people who are able to overcome obesity, overcome illnesses,
become the best versions of themselves,
feel better than they've ever felt in their lives
because of a plant-based diet.
And I've also seen how people, including my family,
'cause both sides of my family
come from farming backgrounds, both parents.
So, my aunts, and uncles are all farmers.
They still own lots of acres and they farm
and they have the health problems
that Klaper and others
who are the same age bracket or older don't have.
And again, those are just examples,
but they're close to home.
I lost multiple relatives recently to diet related diseases
and that does hit close to home.
And I know that a plant-based diet can help with that
because of Forks Over Knives
and Campbell and Esselstyn and Barnard and Klaper
and all those, Ornish, the legends in this game.
And I think for people listening,
it's worth giving it a shot
because the fear of, for me, at least,
and I know you've experienced a little bit of this
in part of your journey.
The fear of something like a heart attack
or a diet related disease that sneaks up on me,
that's kind of scary to me.
And if I can reduce the risk of that
and live a long, healthy life,
that's worth it for me.
And still kill it in the weight room.
Yeah.
The idea that you don't have to compromise that, right?
Yeah, and I think
that's kind of what this book has shown
more than this is the trick to becoming a great athlete.
That's not really what this is about.
It turns out that it is that for the right person
and there are lots of people who, including all of us,
I think, who've kind of experienced
the most success we had athletically
once we went plant-based.
But for me, it's more that
you can do this and you can get all these great benefits
of the longevity, really, and health span.
To me, that's what it's all about.
You mentioned the omnivorous diet,
what's wrong with this.
This is natural,
but natural doesn't really affect,
it doesn't really get into health, right?
Nature selects for reaching reproductive age
and a few years past to raise your kids,
but it's not really about what gets you to 80, 90
and keep moving and being healthy
'cause that doesn't matter fr natural selection.
So, to me, that's where we should think
about not what is,
and I don't honestly know what is the most natural diet
or whatever that even means,
but which one is the data saying is keeping people,
giving them the longest health span,
keeping them mobile and happy and active
and healthy and alive?
And it looks a lot to me
like that's the plant-based diet
that seems to be where the science
is all pointing these days.
Right, you're on-ramp.
Robert was ethics.
Matt, yours was more health-related.
Mine was vanity.
(laughs)
Vanity and health and athletic performance ultimately,
but what's so amazing and beautiful
about how this movement has blossomed
is that now there are all these on-ramps
from the ethical considerations, of course,
to sustainability, to climate change concerns,
environmentally sensitive,
which we all should be, of course,
and the longevity health considerations
of the foods that we eat
and now with this book plant-based athletic performance
and I think it's so great
because just like all the athletes profiled in your book,
different people connect with and resonate
with different individuals, right?
So, not everybody is gonna cotton
onto the ethical argument,
but perhaps they're concerned about the environment
and the way that I look at it,
I look at it as this umbrella lifestyle
that checks every single box.
You can opt out of the chronic lifestyle illnesses
that are unnecessarily killing millions of people.
Obesity rates right now are through the roof.
Diabetes, it's predicted something like 50% of Americans
are gonna be diabetic by 2030.
All of these chronic illnesses are lifestyle illnesses
directly correlated to the foods that we're eating.
Meanwhile, we're decimating the planet
because animal agriculture just requires too many inputs,
too much land, too many resources
for us to sustainably produce enough animal products
for the planet to eat
as we careen down this path towards 10 billion people
living on this planet.
The truth is most people are walking around
thinking about themselves.
They're like, that's fine
but I just want to be buffed
and I wanna eat what I wanna eat
and I wanna be able to kill it in the gym
or qualify for Boston or whatever it is.
And the truth is that all of those goals
are not just possible, but more possible
by dent of learning
what you guys have laid out in this book.
When you read the stories,
one of the things you'll notice is that
what brought people to a plant-based diet
in the first place?
For many people, it's inflammation.
It's pain that they feel even as a young person.
Take David Carter, NFL lineman.
A completely star athlete in his 20's
and he can barely push himself out of a bathtub
because his joints hurt so badly.
And this is a guy who's supposed to be in his prime.
He's playing in the NFL.
And then when he went to a plant-based diet,
not only did he drop weight,
which helped him get rid of some body fat
and then which he later added the weight back on
with more muscle,
he got faster, he got stronger, but the pain went away.
The pain just went away
and his career lasted slightly longer
than the average NFL career
and he's been in incredible shape since then too.
I've seen him in his retirement.
He looks fantastic.
And you look at other athletes.
National champion cyclist,
who had inflammation in their knees
and at age 19 had pain
that made their career suffer to some degree
and then a plant-based diet eradicated that
and they were able to perform and then become champions
at all these different levels.
And I know Fiona Oakes is someone you know
and I've talked to her
and she didn't have a kneecap in her right knee
and wasn't even supposed to walk or let alone run
and went on to overcome that
and has been plant-based since age five or so.
Vegan for nearly 50 years
and has gone on to set Guinness World Records.
And when you look across the board,
men or women, doesn't matter the sport,
so many people came to this lifestyle
to reduce inflammation, improve recovery
and have better results.
And that's what they did
and it's so fun to tell those stories.
There's also stories of people
who all kinds of problems with addiction
and overcame that
like Dotsie Bausch is open about that
and John Joseph rough childhood.
These are inspirational
and in a lot of ways, their success is aspirational.
And that's what I mean.
I get moved every time I read the book
because of those stories.
Just this past week,
have you guys been following the "Iron Cowboy"
who's trying to do these 100 iron mans in a row?
You're aware of this guy?
I was a couple of years ago.
How is he--
No, he did.
Well, he did 50 iron mans in 50 states in 50 days
but now he's in the midst of trying to do this thing
called Conquer 100,
where he's doing 100 iron mans.
He goes out the front door of his house
and does an iron man every day
and he's on day 72 right now or something like that.
Wow.
Sounds insane, right?
Every single day doing an iron man
and he's had struggles that he's overcome.
The whole thing is playing out on Instagram stories
and he's very transparent about his injuries
or what he's dealing with.
This is no small fee.
This is a big deal,
but just the other day,
the reason I'm bringing this up is just the other day,
I think it was yesterday,
he switched up his diet a week ago.
I've been trying to encourage this guy
to go plant-based for a long time.
He flirts with it but then he goes whatever.
I don't know what he was eating
for the first 50 some odd of these iron mans,
but he switched up his diet.
I can only suspect that it became much more whole food based
and more plant forward or plant leaning.
I'm not gonna say he went plant-based.
I know he didn't,
but I know that he started building into his daily routine
a lot more whole foods
and he said that he dropped five pounds of inflammation.
He went and then the next four days,
he felt the best through 68 to 72 of these iron mans.
He said he felt the best that he had felt so far.
So, my point being that
inflammation is not just a real thing.
That's an extreme example
of the impact of the foods that you're eating
on your body's response to exercise induced stress
and how important it is.
So, if you're looking to recover,
eating a plant centric diet, plant-based diet
is gonna take you a long way
towards reducing that inflammation
that impedes your body's ability
to repair itself in between workouts
and in turn, of course,
we'll power youth through bigger breakthroughs
and he would have ordinarily
because that inflammation
stunts your body's ability to adapt and grow.
Yeah, everyone always asks what the mechanism is.
Why does a plant-based diet
supposedly so much better for sports
if you're claiming that it is?
And no one's ever really known.
We don't know what it is.
It seems like you've stopped getting injured.
But Brendan Brazier back in the early 2000's
was saying that when he experimented
with a bunch of diets back in high school,
he found that this was the one that let him recover fastest
and get back so he could get in, whatever,
10 workouts in a week
when the competition could only get six
or something like that.
And so, I think that's a huge part of the story
behind why plant-based diet
seems to be so good for sports
is that the anti-inflammatory compounds
that are just naturally part of it without even trying,
much as if you actually do try
and seek out the foods that that would maximize that,
it just allows you to get back out there faster
and be back out there 100% or very close to it,
rather than every time you come out,
you're a little bit worse
so that eventually an injury follows.
One of the things that I love about the book
is that you really catch us up
on the latest research, right?
If you're starting point is Brendan Brazier's book
or Michael Greger's book or whatever,
there's been a lot of science that's gone down
in the inner looting period, right?
So, when you dug into the science to put this book together,
what did you discover
in terms of the more recent stuff that's been going on
that perhaps people are not aware of?
Yeah, that was really the exciting part
because there haven't been a ton of studies,
but in the last year or two,
they're just exploding
and we even got one in the last minute.
You know how it goes with editing and your final pass.
We snuck one in that I think got in there.
Something like an April 2021 study, a strength study
because we got the endurance study in there.
The one in Montreal already with the plant-based women
versus the omnivorous women
and they all had better performance across the board.
The plant-based athletes had greater endurance,
greater strength, greater whatever the results were.
But now we're seeing it in strength as well
and that's something
that has always been kind of alluding us.
I think we've known even just observationally.
Look at you, look at Matt, look at Scott Jurek,
one of the greatest runners the world has ever known.
Brendan Brazier, Fiona Oakes.
It's so common
for athletes to excel, endurance athletes to excel
on a plant-based diet.
But to now see actual studies
that put men of the same age group, same body size,
the same training background,
put them on a plant-based diet or an animal based diet
and even supplemental protein
that is exclusively plant protein
versus exclusively whey or casein protein,
and see them reach
essentially the exact same strength results
or muscle size results, they measure both often,
I think that is really, really exciting.
And we're not here to say that we're unequivocally better.
We're just better because you can't.
Look at the Olympic games, look at the NFL, the NBA,
there's a lot of people powered by omnivorous diet.
Now, that doesn't speak to their longterm health,
but as far as performance,
we can't necessarily say,
we're just completely better
but what we can say is we now have studies.
We have trials,
we have these things that have been conducted for months
to show that after 12 weeks or whatever period it's been,
those on an exclusively plant-based diet
built the exact same amount of strength
and the same muscle mass
as those on a standard omnivorous athletic diet
and that's exciting.
And some of those have just come out.
I follow Garth Davis and others
who are really quick to share those
and it's like, okay, we gotta get that one in the book now.
Right.
'Cause it's just coming out now.
Right, Matt, you're runner.
Robert, you're a strength athlete.
It's an interesting pairing because I think it is true
sort of to date historically,
the narrative has been coming
from an endurance perspective, right?
All these runners who are experiencing these results
going plant-based,
that's a very different beast
than the strength, agility and power athlete,
whether you're in the NBA
or you're a powerlifter or a bodybuilder,
I think that's where the information gap is a little bit
because people who are interested in that
see all the runners and they're like,
yeah, but that's not my jam.
Right.
But there are Olympian powerlifters, right, who are--
Sure, but those stories are not as widely known.
Sure.
Right, and I think
that's actually what kind of an approach
that James Wilks took with the "Game Changers"
and James is in our book as well,
one of the people we interviewed and shared his story
and I think that was kind of the premise,
was he wanted to speak to those strength athletes.
He has that line in the movie,
all these people like Scott Jurek, they're pretty lean.
They're real lean,
but then he found Patrik Baboumian
and others who are doing this.
And one of my favorite examples
is one of my best friends, Vanessa Espinoza.
I think she's pound for pound
the strongest person that I know.
She's someone who has been plant-based for 20 years,
ethical vegan tattooed all over her.
She was an All-American basketball player.
At only five foot three,
drafted into the WNBA,
went on to become a three-time
Colorado Golden Gloves boxing champion.
Her father was a professional boxer.
So, she got to meet Muhammad Ali
and all these people growing up
and then when she got into power lifting,
she almost set a world record in her very first meet,
where she weighs at 130 pounds
can pull over 400 pounds off the floor,
can squat 365 bench press, 250 or so and we trained together
and she uses 110 pound dumbbells in each hand,
pressing overhead.
We've laid press 1,000 together
and I'm almost twice her size
and she lists the same weight as I do
and she dominates every single sport she's ever been in.
She's been an elite champion at a world-class level
and she's totally humble.
She's under the radar.
She just quietly goes about her business
being pound for pound the best that that I've known.
Is she part of that vegan strong bodybuilding team
that you have?
Yes, she is.
And she's in the book, of course,
because she's just so fascinating.
Right.
And there's others too that are...
That's one of the fun things.
We can name drop.
You and Scott Jurek and some of these bigger names,
James Wilks, Rip,
but for me the fun part is telling the compelling stories
of those who are under the radar
and especially a lot of amazing women out there
who aren't in of the documentaries,
that aren't in books,
like Laura Kline,
who's dominating her sport as a world champion do athlete
and so many others in bodybuilding and other sports.
A bunch of Olympic athletes
that are just doing amazing things
and be able to share those stories.
Yeah, let's do a little myth busting,
starting off with the big one, the elephant in the room.
What could it be?
Yeah, what could this question possibly be?
Where do you get your protein?
Matt, you're a runner.
Robert, you're a power strength athlete.
Where do you get your protein?
We've given the same answer for the years and said
you don't need that much,
which I know is so unsatisfying to people.
I think they just want the secret source
so that we can all know how to do it
but I just don't think about it.
Even recently, I've gotten into kettlebell lifting
much more these days that than a runner
after kind of a prolonged lack of inspiration in sports
and just kind of doing the parenting thing instead
and entrepreneurship and all that
but I'm kind of back now
and really feeling great and having great results
and I don't take protein powder.
I eat beans fairly often.
I eat seitan now and then.
I eat tofu, which is beans,
but if you eat whole foods, it's there.
And the recent athlete studies are saying,
especially for vegetarian or vegan athletes,
and we can come out and say it,
you don't absorb plant protein, I think about 10% lower.
Sorry, you get a 10% less sort of efficiency in absorption.
So, you need a little bit more, for sure,
but it's not a ton more
and three quarters of a gram per pound of body weight,
that would be plenty.
The regular non-athlete recommendation
is much lower than that.
It's something like 0.36 grams per pound per day.
Really not that much.
And I think most people are eating way too much protein,
which I know we all say that,
and people don't seem to believe it.
And I think that's why the question perpetuates,
because there is no great answer like, oh yeah.
This is all you need to do to get that huge amount,
but you just don't need that much.
(chuckles)
That's what it is.
Robert?
Yeah, I think it's almost a separate episode.
This topic could just go on forever,
but I think it starts with,
why do you believe that you need a whole lot of protein
and what is your understanding of protein and what it does
and why are you obsessed with it?
I think it's for everyone to answer.
Why do we try to optimize our protein intake
without optimizing our carbohydrate intake
or optimizing our fat intake
or optimizing our sleep
or optimizing our recovery
or optimizing these other areas of performance?
Our hydration?
We don't.
We focus on protein.
I think it's been
the most brilliantly marketed thing around,
because what it's done
is it's convinced people who are not active, non-athletes,
it's convinced them that they need to reach for protein
in enriched food.
As a beverage when they're sitting on the couch
and watching television.
If they're gonna reach for something,
it's gotta be protein infused,
whether that's a meat product or a beverage
or a protein water or anything else,
because that's been conditioned that,
and even if people who are are quite overweight
or, clearly, we have consumed
a lot of protein in their life,
but they still are afraid that
they just need more of it
and that more is better,
but I'm convinced that that more isn't better
and it can have adverse implications on health
but also I think one thing
that people are totally missing here,
and I don't know if you've talked about this,
I'm sure with other with other guests,
but what happens when you emphasize protein intake?
To me, you completely overlook
the more nutrient rich complex carbohydrates
that provide more fiber, vitamins, minerals,
antioxidants, nitric oxide, water,
and all these other things
to optimize health or optimize performance
but we're focused on an isolated nutrient
that we often take in isolated form
and we miss out on all this other stuff,
because we're filling up on calories
that could have been complex carbohydrates,
which by the way, have a lot of protein in them too.
The way I think about it,
and let me know how this lands for you guys,
is you're correct, Robert.
We've been sold this narrative
that if you don't drink a protein shake
within 10 minutes of waking up in the morning,
that somehow you're not gonna be able to breathe air
in and out of your lungs.
That we're all walking around,
basically, in this constant state of protein deprivation,
but I don't know about you.
I don't know anyone who's gone to the hospital
for a protein deficiency.
I just don't think it's a thing.
I think you're right, Matt,
that almost everybody is far exceeding
their daily recommended intake of protein
but for some reason,
we've been spun this yarn
that we need copious amounts of protein to just live.
And I think it's a fallacy.
In truth when you look at food
and specifically plant-based foods,
when we're talking about protein,
we're talking about amino acids, right?
And we're really talking
about the nine essential amino acids
that our bodies can't synthesize on their own
and that we need to get from our food.
Those amino acids are the building blocks of protein.
But in truth, if you're grazing randomly
on plant-based foods,
it's almost like we've evolved
and the plant kingdom has evolved
to just automatically meet those needs.
You're gonna meet your 10% of calories from protein
just by eating plants of a relative spectrum
of plants throughout the day
and your body takes care of the rest.
It's just not a thing.
So, when you look at that number, what is it?
0.8 grams per kilograms,
kind of like quoted as the main thing,
I've calibrated my protein intake against that
and even when I'm training hard,
I'm still below that,
but I'm improving, I'm not getting injured,
I'm making gains
and it's often led me to question
this whole paradigm altogether.
Garth Davis is probably the most prominent person.
He wrote a whole book, "Proteinaholic"
on this subject matter.
We spend all this time worried about our protein intake.
Meanwhile, we're all fiber deficient.
We're all micronutrient deficient,
where we're not getting enough vitamin D or whatever it is.
We have all these other gaps in our diet
that should be causing us concern
and yet the focus always comes back to protein.
Well, let's continue a little bit further.
The short answer,
which I could have just given you, lead with,
is that if you consume adequate calories
based on your body's needs,
you'll get adequate protein.
You'll get enough protein.
That's the thing.
It's the calorie intake that's important.
So, people talk about, I gotta build muscle.
I've gotta put on mass.
Well, I've put on 100 pounds since I became vegan,
120 pounds to 220 pounds
and for the last decade,
I haven't consumed protein powders,
protein supplements, or even hadn't--
Right, that is what I want get into
because you've gone through this arc
in terms of your relationship with supplements.
Yeah, and with protein.
I can tell you,
I was consuming 300 grams of protein,
5,000 calories a day for a while.
Now I consume less than 100 grams a day
and 200--
Sorry to interrupt
but how much of that previously
was in the form of protein powder?
Six a day.
I worked for Vega for 10 years.
You should have seen.
I was like a GNC in my basement.
It was unbelievable.
I had access to anything I wanted
and I used it as long as it was plant-based.
I was doing, really,
sometimes five, six protein drinks a day
and I, actually, got bigger and stronger,
just overall better performance,
the best I've ever been.
Later in life,
late 30's, early 40's now a decade without
any of those sports supplements just vitamin B12.
Was it just curiosity,
or what was the impetus
to ditch that stuff and see what would happen without it?
(laughs lightly)
It came from when I worked
in the Forks Over Knives office
and I was down in Vega like crazy
and Brian and Robbie
were the only other guys in the office for a while.
And they were teasing me all the time.
Yeah, rabbits gotta have this.
Protein drink to tie his shoes
and another supplement to walk across the room.
They just kept on getting on me.
Here I was working for this film about whole foods
in reversing disease and being your best health
and all this stuff
and I was just sitting in the office
drinking powders all day long.
Right, but I get it
because you're trying to make gains.
It's one thing.
Forks over knives is really about
combating chronic lifestyle.
It's not about killing it in the gym.
Right, but their personal argument
was that you can achieve these things
without the supplementation,
without the emphasis on protein.
Right.
So, I--
But that was a relatively untested hypothesis.
Right, and I completely argued with it.
I disagreed with it.
And so, I decided
I'm gonna enroll in Dr. Campbell's
plant-based nutrition program,
Center for Nutrition Studies.
So, I did that 2012
and in that course,
I was kind of hilarious looking back.
I wrote papers arguing
what does 80 year old skinny Campbell know
about building muscle and being a champion bodybuilder.
I argued, I wrote papers that if you take a NFL team,
put them on a high protein diet
and another NFL team of equal skill and talent,
put them on a low protein diet,
the high protein diet is gonna smash the other team.
And then I said take the skill set out
and just do it weightlifting maybe.
Just something that's just a really easy thing to measure.
The high protein people are gonna win every time.
And I argued and I argued,
and then I decided to do the one thing
that so many people are unwilling to do,
especially in my space and the vegan bodybuilding space
was to 100% give it a try.
Cut out all sports supplements, except for vitamin B12
or maybe something else that was necessary,
vitamin D or DHA, EPA, whatever,
but I really wasn't doing that.
It was just B12
and to cut the emphasis on protein,
just stop thinking about it.
Even to this day, I hold the tofu place.
That's what I really do.
Not because you were convinced,
but because you wanted to test this yourself.
I had to test it.
So, what happened?
What happened was
it just happened to be the same time
that I was getting tired of bodybuilding.
And so, I'd peaked at 195 pounds at the time
and I dropped all the way down to 165
because I was pursuing running.
And so, now it's like, oh, okay.
That makes sense.
His low protein diets not working anymore
and I ran a bunch of half marathons with my wife
and I ran 5k and finished in the top five
in every race that I competed in.
I have a background in running, of course.
So, it came naturally for me
and it felt good to be back doing it again.
I weighed 165 pounds.
And then the Eve of the Fort Collins marathon in Colorado,
this woman recognized me at the gym
and said, "You're Robert Cheeke, right?"
It ended up being Vanessa Espinoza,
who's now one of my absolute best friends.
And I kind of immediately puffed up like a rooster
'cause I was so small
and she's like, "You're one of my heroes,"
and all this stuff
and I saw her again a week later again
and we started training together.
And in 18 months, I went from 165 pounds to 205 pounds,
bigger and stronger than I've ever been in my life
while riding shredded and following this low protein,
no supplement except for B12 approach.
And it was amazing.
And that's when I was convinced
that the nutrients per calorie that you get
from a whole food plant-based diet
when you emphasize, especially, complex carbohydrates,
it's just doing things.
Like Matt said, it's doing things to help your recovery.
You're naturally reducing inflammation.
You're not eating pro inflammatory foods.
You're eating anti-inflammatory foods.
I could train.
I was lifting 120 pound dumbbells in each hand over head.
I'd never done that before
and this was all--
So, you were actually were lifting more.
You were stronger.
Yeah, and bigger.
165 to 205.
And before, remember I had maxed out at 195
with five protein drinks a day,
four frozen burritos a day,
seven cliff bars a day, doing whatever I could,
because it was hard for me to put on mass.
And then this past year with the quarantine and everything,
I thought, man, how cool would it be
if I could reach that milestone
of putting on 100 pounds total.
So, I started the year at 208 or so
and I got up to 223 at one point,
slimmed down a little bit for this podcast.
(laughs)
My belt wouldn't even work anymore,
but I got really strong.
I'm still.
I'm just using 110 pound dumbbells, no spotter needed.
I just do my thing
and that's on a low protein approach.
And I think people need to put it to the test
to see for themselves,
because what you're missing by focusing on protein
could be all those benefits of a complex carbohydrate diet
that help with energy, recovery,
overall fuel and performance
and I think if people can give that a try,
they're gonna see a world of difference.
Right, and so where do you fall now both of you guys?
Matt, you've been quiet over there.
(chuckles)
I know Robert likes to talk,
but we gotta give Matt a chance to talk a little bit here.
(laughs)
In terms of supplementation as a whole,
when we're thinking about making sure
that we were getting adequate omega-3s
and DHA and iron and all the other things,
I know you talked about this in the book,
but where do you fall in terms of sourcing
from whole food sources
versus some level of responsible supplementation?
Matt, you have supplements.
So, I'm a believer in responsible supplementation.
I think a lot of people,
regardless of your diet,
are walking around with certain deficiencies.
So, how do you think about and speak to that?
Yeah, so it's good to separate
the sports supplementation
from supplementation for long-term health
and also just short well-being.
So, the protein stuff to me
is an optional supplement.
It's useful for some athletes, perhaps,
it's useful for older people.
Like I said, I don't take protein powder,
but I do give some to my kids who are both athletes.
I think it's one of those sorts of parenting things
where I don't wanna do anything wrong possibly for them
so that--
Yeah, you were talking about that
in that podcast recently.
And as a parent myself, I'm thinking,
yeah, I've lived this, I believe it, I advocate it,
but I really don't wanna screw up my kids life.
Right, I just did it.
When you're looking at your kids,
you're like, am I doing this right?
I wanna make sure that they mature and grow and develop
the way that they should be.
Yeah, and there are also
some different forces at play with kids
just because in many cases,
like at high levels of youth sports,
they're competing against kids who are eating
a diet that's gonna make them perhaps unnaturally large,
like most people eat.
So, there's a little bit of a balancing act there
while also really still putting their longterm health
first and foremost.
And that's honestly why I developed that protein batter,
was to give to them.
But anyway, back to the short term
and the long-term supplements but not sports supplements.
Yeah, a plant-based diet, like you said,
is so rich in so many things
but I think you're kidding yourself if you don't admit
that it is deficient in B12.
That's the one that pretty much is universally agreed upon.
There are people who still argue
you'll get it from dirty produce or whatever,
but with modern agriculture,
it's just not in the soil like it was,
and we don't eat the soil.
We don't consume soil like we used to.
We just used to get into our bodies.
So, that's a big one.
You've mentioned D3.
DHA, EPA, those are two omega-3 fatty acids
that just don't really show up in plant-based foods,
except for algae.
You can get ALA, another type of omega-3
from walnuts and flax seeds
and if you eat and get enough of it,
some people can convert that into DHA and EPA.
But I think a lot of people are fooled by packaging saying,
hey, this is high in omega-3s,
thinking I'll just get that from my omega-3s,
but really it's...
And it's something that I'm grateful
that the awareness is increasing among vegan doctors
and even among vegan non-doctors
that many people should be supplementing with DHA or EPA.
Which you do it in an algae bit.
In an algae form, yeah.
So, those are the big three,
It's actually four,
but I just think of DHA and EPA as three.
And then there's more.
There's K2, iodine, selenium, zinc,
these minerals and K2 that are just harder to get.
They're not impossible to get.
They're in things.
Zinc is in plenty of things
that just that we don't absorb it that much.
So, depending on your diet,
you may or may not be getting these foods.
So, we make a supplement that has all those things,
but that's kind of where I am.
I think those big three are important.
I think after that, it's sort of an insurance policy.
For me, it's like, why not?
I don't have any need to, as we talked about earlier,
defend this diet by like being so pure
or to say I can do this without supplements.
That doesn't matter to me.
What matters to me is what the science shows
leads to long-term health and that's where I come out.
Right, so how do you address the criticism
that I'm sure you guys have heard,
where, well, if you need to supplement with B12,
obviously this is an inadequate diet.
It's exactly what I said before.
You can make the natural argument,
but then I'll make the empirical science argument.
These are great examples.
It feels good to go out in the sun and get vitamin D,
because take your shirt off and go out in the sun.
That feels good.
It's probably a practice that natural selection rewarded.
It probably made us healthy and helped us reach that age,
where we would have offspring
and be around to care for them for a little while
but then skin cancer catches up with you
and natural selection doesn't care about that.
So, to me, supplementing with vitamin D
is probably the better choice
than to do what is the "natural way" of getting it.
Now, I think it's still good
to get some naturally, of course.
Be outside or expose some skin
but I think the dangers of sun radiation
are probably worth supplementing D instead of getting it.
But the D thing really isn't even a vegan thing.
Right.
I had Dr. Andrew Weil in here the other day
and he's banging the vitamin D drum.
And he basically said,
if you live north of like Atlanta,
you're too far north
to really get your vitamin D from the sun
with the exception of a couple of months a year
during maybe spring and summer
and that's basically it.
So, there's a huge swath of the population
that's vitamin D deficient
and because we essentially live in doors
almost all the time,
it's the responsible thing to do
is to make sure that you're supplementing appropriately
or just getting your blood levels checked
to make sure that you're on top of it,
but just going out in the sun in November,
if you live in Boston is not gonna do it.
Right, and like Matt said,
we don't have to sit here and defend the diet,
but I did make a little kind of a funny comment in the book
about who's out there taking all the Flintstones vitamins?
It's not people on a plant-based diet.
They're getting vitamins from produce,
from fruits and vegetables for the most part.
And so, you look at the general population.
They're in many cases, supplementing more
and growing up on a farm
and having an animal agriculture professor as a father,
I know that animal feed is heavily supplemented as well.
In fact, my dad worked as a consultant
for some of these ingredients
like Yucca and other things,
these various supplements that go into animal food,
which then goes into the animal tissue,
which people consume.
And so, I think a lot more people are supplementing
than they think
by taking their daily vitamins--
Well, there's the second hand stuff
that you get from eating the animals.
Right, and even all the four to five muscle milk
and all that stuff too.
That it's, well, this is good for protein,
but it's all four to five with all this other stuff too.
You also have a whole section in the book
about, basically, natural supplements.
They're not technically supplements,
but they are a supplement to your typical diet
in the sense that there are things
that aren't found just in a whole food
that you're gonna eat.
So, let's spend a little time talking about what those are.
Caffeine, of course,
you go into adaptogen,
endurance boosting, foods like beets.
Tart cherry juice is a great one.
You didn't have cordyceps in there though.
I guess that's technically an adaptogen.
Yeah, it wasn't listed.
We may have mentioned--
I know maca was left out of the adaptogens
and I was like, you gotta get that in there.
You've read enough books.
They're just kind of (mumbles).
But you did have creatine in there,
which I thought was interesting.
So talk a little bit about that.
Matt, I've been doing--
(mumbles) people in here were like
creatine is a strength thing, right?
Yeah, I like creatine.
I think the studies that are out on it
and it's been studied now for quite a while,
I know there are anecdotal stories
of people who whatever happens to their kidney or something,
but when you look at the science,
it appears that it is completely safe.
I don't give it to my kids
because there's not enough science there yet.
It's not in plant-based foods by and large.
So we are getting less than an omnivore would.
It's also been shown to improve memory and things like that
when vegetarians or vegans take it.
So, there's some cognitive benefits.
So, I think it's a good thing.
It's not something that I take a ton of
or would wanna go crazy with, but I don't know.
I don't think Robert (mumbles), right?
No, actually it was the worst for me ever
of any supplement I ever took.
I couldn't even finish workouts.
It was so hard on my stomach, just stomach pains.
And then I tried CRE alcohol in like a liquid form
instead of the powder.
I just couldn't get it to work for me.
And I was into it just because I was trying to use
any body building supplement that was natural and--
Is it natural?
How do they synthesize it?
How do they make it?
I don't even know.
Well, I mean, everything is lab-made these days,
but I mean, it's natural as far as not a banned substance,
not an anabolic steroid or growth hormone
or something like that.
But it's not derived from animal products?
No, they'll say vegan right on the package.
I don't know from a chemistry background
how this stuff is made,
but pretty much everything is just lab made these days
by different chemicals together.
And here's your powder certified vegan creatine.
I don't know behind the scenes, the white coats,
how that's made, but it's out there.
And I think Matt, we mentioned this in the book that
vegans and vegetarians tend to benefit the most
because if they're creating intake levels
were already kind of low,
once you start taking it,
you get that faster.
You get the results a bit faster or more significant.
Basically, it helps retain water in your muscles and--
It's a vanity supplement.
(laughs hysterically)
But it also gives you some more mass.
That's what I argued in the book,
I said if you have an extra five or 10 pounds,
you have more mass to move more mass with
and therefore can enhance strength gains.
You have more mass to work with,
which is what helps as you're building muscle, right?
I mean, as I go from 165 to 220,
the more mass I have to work with,
the more strength that I get.
I'm just have more space.
I have just bigger whims.
I can move more weight and then I get stronger
and then I get bigger
'cause I listed the muscle growth in that process.
So, creatine kind of help in those kind of ways.
To get back to less controversial,
and tart cherry juice is a great one.
I give that to my kids all the time.
That's kind of my post-workout drink,
uses the tart cherry juice thing.
Again, just with the anti-inflammation,
that's been shown to reduce muscle soreness
and inflammation.
So, that's a great one.
Ginger, turmeric, these do the same things.
And that's what I was saying earlier about,
plant-based foods have
lots and lots of anti-inflammatory compounds
without even trying.
But these particular ones, they really back at it.
Who knows if it's a placebo effect
or just ginger shadow wake you up like nothing else.
I like working those things in,
but they're supplements.
They're not necessary added to diet.
Your son is killing it in soccer, right?
You guys like relocated so that he could be
on an amazing team.
He is.
Yeah, which is not quite as dramatic as it sounds.
The reality is I was driving like two to three hours,
three times a week, both ways.
And it was like, this is just killing us.
So the new MLS team that starts next season,
there's one called Charlotte FC and in North Carolina.
And so, he got into their youth program,
which is quite an opportunity.
So, we started doing that and we were driving there
and then we were like,
well, why don't we just get an apartment there
and see how that is?
And we did that and worked out great.
And then we found all these other soccer opportunities
in Charlotte.
So, yeah, we've kind of oriented our lives,
as I mentioned earlier,
a lot of it around the kids as athletes now,
or the kids as humans now really, and it's been so much fun.
I've really, really loved being a soccer dad.
And your kids are plant-based?
Yeah, completely plant-based.
And performing as athletes?
They're doing really good.
Yeah, I think...
I don't know, it's like I said,
there are things I do worry about like the size,
if they're competing against kids who are eating
less natural diet, or I shouldn't say less natural,
one that encourages extreme growth perhaps,
but they both have really, really great endurance.
And I think that's probably a testament to their diet.
And what about the socialization aspect of it
with their peers?
So they both grew up for the most part
in Asheville, North Carolina,
where everybody eats some kind of weird diet.
(mumbles)
Yeah, so, it's really nothing different.
But Charlotte, that's a different vibe.
Charlotte is a different vibe,
but it's also a different time.
It's these days we tell people we're vegan
and they're like,
oh yeah, well, you can go to this vegan place down the road
or get an impossible burger.
No one thinks that much of it, I don't think anymore,
which is a very good thing.
And what about with their friends?
How does that work?
Only recently have we had little things
where a kid will make fun of it or something.
And only tell me once he was practicing up
with the older age group kids and somehow someone,
one of them saw his Instagram or something
and knew that he was plant-based.
Can I shout out his Instagram?
It's Mountain Football Kid.
Sure.
What is it?
Mountain Football Kid.
He kills it on Instagram.
All right, everybody get down that.
Let's blow up this kid Instagram.
That was one of my missions.
One of my missions was to try to save
Mountain Football Kid on this Rich Roll Podcast.
Good, well, we accomplished that.
I'm gonna make a big deal about it now.
Good, that would be awesome.
Everybody stop what doing right now,
Mountain Football Kid and try see where we can get,
how followers do you have right now?
I think he said that like 2000 now or so.
2000, that's pretty good for high school kid.
I'm teaching him how to do
How old is he?
Content making.
He's 11.
11?
All right.
We monitor it, don't worry, it not-
Let's get it up to like 10,000.
Let's do that.
That'd be good.
And he's trained in Spain, right?
Multiple years in Spain.
Yeah, is a lot time he was over that.
He was with the Atlanta MLS team.
I've watched Holden.
Matt and I went to a soccer game.
We met up in person to work on some of the book aspects
and Holden then was a schooling,
everybody on the field during halftime with this like
semi-pro game or something.
And I've known Holden since he was born.
Yeah, that's right.
So, we go back a long way.
But anyway, someone saw his Instagram
and they were making fun of him or something
during a practice.
And it was the only time I've really ever
dealt with anything like that,
where he told me in the car and he was sort of embarrassed
that it had happened.
And I was like, oh, I mean, whatever.
And we just talked about it and it lasted about 10 minutes.
And then the next time he didn't care.
They're so comfortable with it
because they know that's what I do.
It's a very much part of their being.
It's not like just the thing we're trying that's weird
and they're ready to ditch it whenever.
They know it's--
They're into it.
Yeah, so to be made fun of for 10 minutes
doesn't really matter.
That's cool.
That's no small feat.
I feel like kids either define themselves
in terms of trying to like live up to the example
their parents set,
or they sort of push the boundaries and try to figure out
who they are by defining themselves
in opposition to their parents.
We're dealing with a little of that right now.
So, maybe that's coming, but from the beginning,
I've said to them,
we're not gonna cook it in the house,
but if you guys want to have a hamburger one day, tell me.
I'm not here to limit your joy.
I know in some capacity I am,
if they started eating that stuff routinely, I would say,
"I don't think this is the healthiest thing you could do,"
but I don't want to dictate their ethics and say,
you're not allowed to do this.
So I said, if you ever want that,
you tell me and we'll work that out.
I don't know how, but we'll do that.
I think that's a really important point.
That deserves a little bit of attention,
because I think by doing that you're basically accomplishing
a couple of things.
First of all,
you're removing all of the kind of tension around that idea,
because there's nothing to rebel against.
Right, you're like, one hamburger?
Here, I'll give you a hamburger, right?
So, they're not gonna get any rush out of being like,
I'm doing something wrong, right?
You're like, it's cool.
And secondarily, you're saying I'm not gonna get caught up
in the minutia of your daily choices.
What I'm interested in is creating a foundation of education
and healthy habits that will serve you
throughout the rest of your life.
It's not about that hamburger.
It's about how are you gonna be eating in five years,
10 years, 15 years from now.
Yap, exactly.
Yeah, back to a little bit of myth-busting
or just kind of top level subjects.
Another thing that comes up a lot,
I'm sure you fielded this inquiry frequently,
is, okay, maybe I could be interested in this,
but this sounds like a lot of work.
What am I gonna be?
In that kitchen all day long doing meal prep
and I'm gonna have to buy all these exotic foods
and I'm gonna have to be thinking about what I'm eating
all the time.
It's just I'm busy.
(chuckles)
Yeah, well, maybe I'm a good person to answer this because
I don't know how to cook anything
unlike you guys who have cookbooks.
I can't make anything,
and I've been doing this for 25 years.
So, it's totally easy for me.
Largely, I eat a lot of simple foods.
I eat a lot of produce.
I eat foods that I really enjoy, lots of different fruits
and foods that are already prepared.
I rolled into town and picked up some plant-based sushi,
whole foods market or I can get it anywhere.
It doesn't have to be in an elitist kind of store,
like whole foods.
It can be anywhere.
And just the accessibility
of anything that you already enjoy,
burritos, tacos, pizza, sandwiches,
wraps, salads, sushi, fur, whatever it is.
It's there, it's available.
And I'm someone who is a recovering workaholic.
I used to have to maximize every one
of the 1,440 minutes We have each day.
And that goes back to my early days of
hustle, hustle and grind.
Gary Vaynerchuk inspired in 2009 when I met him
and then used to kind of follow that crush at approach.
And even as someone who is obsessively busy,
it worked for me because I could just go down the street
to someplace and get a burrito,
or I'd have a bunch of fruit at home
and not just boring fruit.
At one time I counted,
I had 19 different types of fruit at home at one time.
And that can be berries and melons and citrus
and lots of different things, avocado.
And so, there's a variety of there.
You just grab them.
You grab some blueberries,
grab some raspberries, strawberries,
watermelon, pineapple, whatever
and then the heavier stuff.
It doesn't really take much work.
I say I can't cook,
but I obviously know how to make rice or pasta
and those kinda things.
So, it can be staples.
They're heavier,
more calorie dense,
you add other things to them.
Some olives, some sauce, whatever.
The point is,
it's more accessible now than ever before.
I'm sure that's just on repeat now.
Everyone's repeating that.
You can just get fast food places.
Not that we're encouraging people to eat fast food,
but the accessibility of a plant-based diet
has never been greater than it is today.
And it doesn't have to be exotic.
Doesn't have to be expensive.
And you just go down the street
and find some great vegan foods.
Yeah, the floor for me is always,
at least within United States.
I know that pretty much every city I go to,
there's gonna be a Chipotle and I can get a burrito bowl
or vegan burrito bowl, vegan burrito.
So, it doesn't matter where I'm headed.
If I'm headed to a city,
I don't have to think about it.
There's always that.
If I can't find something else,
I'll always be able to feed myself there.
(laughs)
Yeah, and now with Taco Bell,
it's not the healthiest,
but there are a lot of good vegan options there.
If you want something different--
Are there?
Oh, tons.
Yeah, like black bean, anything now.
In Taco Bell..
That's what I was gonna say.
That was the staple in the '90s
was Taco Bell before Chipotle.
That's where the vegans met.
Well, here's the danger, though,
and maybe we could talk about this for a couple of minutes,
which is, and you alluded to this
at the beginning of the conversation
because plant-based vegan eating has become so popular
and we have food scientists
who figured out how to make plant based analogs
to all our favorite animal product foods.
There is just a proliferation
of vegan junk food everywhere you look
to the point where almost every single fast food restaurant
has a Beyond Meat or an Impossible Burger.
So, you could literally just go back
to being that drive-thru guy and say,
"I'm vegan and I'm healthy,"
when you're truly, really, if we're being honest,
not eating any better than you were
when you were on the junk food diet.
Which I think that's a very real concern.
It's cool that so much of the population
is now able to incorporate more plant-based foods.
And I think something like 60 or 70% of people
in surveys say they are incorporating
more plant-based foods now.
That's awesome.
It's great for animals.
Yeah, from an ethical
and environmental perspective, fantastic.
Right, and for the time being, that's a good thing.
What I wonder about,
and my friend Ray Kornheiser
has suggested this to me a long time ago
is what happens when they start studying people
who eat "plant-based diets" 10, 15 years from now,
when people are doing what you just described.
They're eating the junk food standard American diet,
just a vegan version of it.
And then the headlines are
plant-based diet
doesn't, actually, work.
Plant-based diet
doesn't work.
Yeah, (chuckles) exactly.
So, I think that's a real danger as great as it all is
as much as these conveniences are nice
for people who are kind of already in
and I think certainly it's gonna create a bunch of vegans
who, or I shouldn't say vegans,
plant-based eaters,
who are part-time plant-based eaters,
who get into it and then they realize
via the Impossible Whopper or whatever
that they actually really like thinking about their food
and that's just their very, very first step
when they might not have imagined
being able to do this before,
but then two or three years from now,
they are doing all the work you just described.
Yes, it is a lot of work to really eat healthily
and to make food, I don't wanna say your hobby,
but one of the important pillars of your life
is putting good food on the table
or getting it in the car for a soccer trip
or getting it in your kids or whatever.
That's real work
and I think the way to get to that
really is like any other.
I'd be like, if you are super into gonna the gym
and you know all these different lifts
and you know where you stand with each of those lifts
and you know your personal best,
that also took a lot of work
to get that level of development.
It's the same way with food,
but you kinda start right where you are.
If you're inspired, then sure,
go plant-based overnight,
just see what happens,
but if it doesn't work,
which in many, many cases, it won't
because it's such a drastic shift,
then do the small steps approach.
Start with just breakfast,
do that for two weeks, if you want,
and then maybe start pushing the line
to later and later in the day.
But I just think starting where you are
and kinda letting it become almost like a hobby for you,
then, yeah, it's worth,
but anyone who knows who's done it,
it just starts to feel really fun.
It just feels really good to being eating really well.
Yeah, I agree wholeheartedly with that idea
that everybody needs an entry point and a semi soft landing
and if that means going to Carl's Jr.
or whatever fast food outlet
to get your plant-based version of a burger
and you enjoy that,
then suddenly you're on your little journey, right?
And for a lot of people, myself included,
that leads to much more engagement,
emotional attachment to the foods that you're eating,
which leads to education,
which leads to these improvements.
But I will say myself
as somebody who has a history of addiction
and has been plant-based for 15 years,
it's like (exhales) I could go to Umami Burger
and get that but it tastes so good.
It tastes exactly like (mumbles)
and that's vegan and it's plant-based.
And I will play that game in my head
and I will indulge with that
and then I'm like, why'd I do that.
And it's sorta back to square one
in terms of from a health perspective on what I'm doing,
but because those options are so readily available now,
it means that if you wanna do this properly
from a health perspective,
that you do have to be a little bit more rigorous
than maybe we had to eight years ago.
Yeah, what I always said was
that what's so great about a plant-based diet,
this is before it was really convenient
to get all these plant-based junk foods,
is the inconvenience.
As much as everyone thinks this is inconvenient,
that's what makes it great.
Because now if you're going on a road trip,
and this is me speaking in 2010,
you have to actually plan for that road trip.
You're not gonna have any food.
And when you plan,
you're not gonna plan to eat junk food.
You tend to plan on good fruits, vegetables,
whatever's kind of easy.
You make something nice for the trip.
Or if you're going out too,
if I was gonna have beers and watch a game at a bar
with my friends,
I learned pretty quickly
that there's nothing there for me to eat that's any good.
So, I'll just eat ahead of time at my house
and maybe I'll still drink a beer,
but I'm like, I don't need to--
But now they might have plant-based Buffalo wings
or something like that.
Right, exactly.
So, that inconvenience is gone, which is cool,
but it's also something
it's not any easier than ever,
well, I shouldn't say that, to eat healthy
'cause there are increasing number
of actually really healthy options thanks to technology.
They're getting frozen things
or packaged things that actually are healthy
and they're maintaining freshness
and that's all great.
Yeah.
And I think it's really just being mindful,
just being mindful and deliberate.
So, how do we avoid
just eating vegan junk food all the time?
Well, I think with some discipline,
just like when we were kids,
we didn't have a lot of our own money.
We thought, man, as soon as I get money,
I'm just gonna eat ice cream every single day, all day,
because that's what I want.
But we (chuckles) express some sort of level of discipline
and don't do that.
Right now, I have the means to go have vegan pizza
or vegan burgers or vegan ice cream every single day
if I want, but I don't
because there's not a good nutritional return
on investment there.
I'm mindful of other things.
I'd much rather have antioxidant rich berries
and fruits and leafy green.
And you know how you feel,
the way you feel is vastly different.
And I know how to make it fun too.
This food doesn't have to be boring.
You can make great foods for breakfast, lunch, dinner.
Think about this.
How many people only once,
especially here in the U.S. let's say,
only once they adopted a plant-based diet,
did they start exploring Thai food and Indian food
and Ethiopian food, Vietnamese.
I know this.
That was me.
Yeah, for decades.
My wife was the same.
So many others were the same, myself included too.
And now that's often my favorite cuisine.
Indian food, Ethiopian food, Thai food.
That's it.
That's my game.
And that's through a plant-based diet
that diversified my palette.
And to realize that those foods
are very often rice and vegetable dishes.
Right.
And also I wanna mention this.
I've done quite a bit of traveling.
Now, some of it was just while I worked on cruise ships,
but I have been to over 30 countries
and I haven't found any place,
whether it was Russia or Poland or anywhere in the world,
that was a challenge to do this lifestyle.
I've been through China and Indonesia
and Thailand and Australia
and all these different corners of the world
and it's all there, right?
In fact, it's plentiful in some of those areas.
It's plant-based diet.
Yeah, that's from
my experience as well.
And in Southeast Asia
is probably my favorite place on the planet.
That's where I would thrive like crazy.
Mangosteen, the amazing fruit there
and the weather and the exercise and outdoor.
That's the thing.
This diet isn't, I don't think,
just for people who can pay for a $10 burger,
but the plant-based foods are available anywhere
and it's incredibly affordable
if you stick to a lot of the basics,
the right--
The other thing too,
that people think because it's so heavily associated
with the whole foods life, right,
that people think it's expensive.
But as Rip Esselstyn is always fond of saying,
we're talking about popper food.
It's rice and beans produce.
It's not about being fancy.
It's not about chia seeds and hemp seeds.
Those things are great
but essentially, these are staples
that humans have been eating for millennial,
irrespective of your, kind of, social or economic status.
And look at the blue zones.
Some of the consistent themes
throughout the longest lived people
in all different cultures
and all corners of the world are legumes.
I think that's a common theme
that binds their diets together
in a heavy plant-based diet,
maybe minimal animal protein.
And these are foods that are incredibly affordable.
I even wrote a 35 page article on that.
It meant to be 800 words
but as you can tell,
I'm a little bit long-winded at times.
Yeah.
And it would--
I get your emails.
I know.
Oh, you do.
I didn't know that.
(laughs)
Oh, that's me.
Oh, so, you saw the one yesterday.
Yeah, I did see it.
Oh, that's great.
That's great.
I did not know that, but I appreciate that.
I'm actually honored.
Yeah, so, I wrote all about that
and it turns out the most affordable foods
when you take out government subsidies
and all these kinds of things
and then you get the nutrition per calorie
I measured all this stuff.
The number one food in the world is the mighty lentil
as far as the actual nutritional return on investment
you get per cent, per penny.
And then all the foods you'd expect.
Pinto beans, rice oats, all right up there as well.
And these are foods that should be, hopefully, accessible
to most people
and they're great nutritionally,
they last for a long time,
you can make them in batches.
That's another thing we talk about in the book
and, oftentimes, in our own writing
and our own presentations
is that if you can batch cook stuff,
if you've prepared at home
a big batch of brown rice, lentils,
garbanzo beans, Pinto beans, black beans,
siloed greens already ready, sliced up fruit, right?
Whatever the case is,
you can just mix and match right there.
You can make a difference in--
Right, this has provided a foundation
for a million different kinds of things.
'Cause what happens if you don't have that preparation?
I'm hungry.
I gotta run to a restaurant real quick.
I gotta order something to be delivered at my door.
I just need to eat this frozen food for the microwave
that's in the freezer
because I need these chips right now, corn chips.
I need the salt, the sugar, the fat.
I need something.
So, we can avoid that.
And that's one of the big downfalls too.
Like chef AJ says, talking about junk food,
if it's in your house, it's in your mouth.
If you can be a little prepared
and plant-based athletes are no different.
In fact, maybe even more so.
If you can be prepared nutritionally,
man, you get your pre-workout food is right there.
Your fruit or whatever the case is,
your post-workout food is right there.
It's ready.
You don't need to go.
'Cause when you're hungry, you're gonna spend extra money.
You're gonna buy the wrong things
and you're gonna say,
man, I just worked for 90 minutes in that workout
and now this is what I have to show for it.
I'm gonna load up on all this stuff
that's not health promoting.
Yeah, in a macro sense,
if you talk to Dan Buettner,
he'll tell you that the way that we're gonna shift people
towards healthier lifestyles
is by changing their environments.
You've gotta create bike lanes.
On a kind of urban city community level,
you have to create systems and structures
that make the healthy choice
the easy and convenient choice
and I think we can all do this in a micro sense
in our homes with our refrigerators
to the extent that you remove the unhealthy choices
from arms reach
and you always have the healthy choice available to you.
It just makes it so much more likely
that you're gonna end up eating better
because that's, what's right in front of you.
I think I heard,
'cause I heard "Atomic Habits."
Oh, James Clear.
Yeah, on your podcast
saying he puts the beer in the very back of the fridge.
Right.
It's almost cliched.
It's like just change your mind,
just kind of don't have it in your house
but that stuff is so effective.
I really think if you can just design your environment
on this in this micro way,
we're putting, we're about to trick,
the sticky notes up on the mirror
that reminds you of the do your daily meditation.
Because so much we just forget.
Those little environmental changes
I think are way more powerful than the kind of willpower
I'm gonna remember to do this.
Sure, they seem hokey, but they actually really work.
Right.
And habits change as a result of consistency
and the way that you say it
and the way that Sonya Looney says it in the book,
I love it.
I actually use this word now.
I used to think consistency
was the most important word in the world
and now I like the expression showing up.
If you just show up every day,
and that's with exercise,
that's taking your dogs for a walk,
that's with contributing to your environment,
it's with nutrition,
it's with exercise,
there's there's days we don't want to, right?
We don't wanna go to the gym.
There's a basketball game I'd rather watch
or there's Twitter comments I'd rather chime into
or something on the internet I wanna do,
but if you could just show up day after day,
and that's nutritionally too
keeping the right food in the right place,
but also exercise.
How much of a test was this past year, right?
With quarantine and pandemic stuff.
What are you gonna do
within your capacity to overcome that?
What kind of habits can you develop?
Because as Matt and I both know,
and we've written a lot about this,
willpower and discipline can only take you so far,
but the way you say it, Rich, showing up.
You mentioned something like
just put your shoes on
or put them at the door and go outside.
You don't feel like to run, but give yourself five minutes.
That could turn into 50 minutes, right?
(chuckles)
That's one thing, I think,
I hope resonates with a lot of people.
Yeah, well, you've got a lot of stuff
in the book about that,
having an accountability partner
and setting goals.
So, you have all the science,
you've got all these athlete testimonials and stories,
and then you kind of have this self-help piece
about how you actually
implement all of these things in your life
in an effective way
and then you've got the recipe.
So, it's all in there, right?
The whole--
And the day in the life.
And the day in the life, that's right.
So, we were both laughing
because Matt and I are both obsessed with self-help stuff.
Oh, you are?
Yeah, we just are.
That's the tone of a lot of it in the book
is that you have to have this belief in self.
You have to have gone through some of your own struggles,
either internally or externally
and come out better on the other side.
That stuff is just so powerful.
And we're both just big fans
of that kind of personal development and self-help.
And so, we couldn't help but put that tone in there.
And then some of the fun things like the recipes,
you'll notice, they're all contributed by the athletes.
It's not my way of eating.
It's not Matt's way of eating.
We're not telling you to subscribe to a certain dogma.
This is what James Wilks has for breakfast.
Right, this is what
these people are actually doing.
Yeah, this is what these Olympic athletes
and what Julia Murray eats
and there's so much variety in there.
There's something for everybody.
Well, on that subject of kind of Day In the Life,
look, over the course of the history of this podcast,
it's tipped very heavily towards the endurance athlete
in many ways
and we've had lots of runners and plant-based.
I was like, here's how I do it.
And I have had strength athletes on.
I've had Niemeyer on,
I had Patrik Baboumian on a while back,
but I think it would be good
to spend a few minutes talking about
how you do it, Robert,
if somebody is listening to this and they're like,
I'd love, Rich, but he does the soldier stuff.
I just wanna go into the gym
and put on some mass and get stronger.
How does Robert do it?
Yeah, I think, potatoes are your friend.
Potatoes, yams, sweet potatoes.
These are the kinds of foods.
So, I look at things
and I wrote quite a bit about this in the book
about calorie density and nutrient density,
basically, looking at the nutrients per calorie,
but also focusing on those calorie rich foods,
like Matt was talking about.
If you're gonna put on some mass,
you've gotta have the nut butters,
you've gotta have the legumes, the grains
nuts and seeds themselves in some capacity.
You've got to have the calories there.
And so, that's what I focus on.
For me, it's exciting to weigh around 220 pounds
as someone who as a teenager
was always aspiring to be like this pro wrestler guy
and to now maintain that
and have the ability to lift some heavy weights.
It starts with understanding
what your true calorie needs are.
I use the Harris-Benedict equation,
the Harris-Benedict calculator,
which factors based on your gender, age, height, weight,
and very importantly, your activity level
how many calories you expend every day.
If you don't have that knowledge,
you're just guessing about how much to eat
in order to put on mass or to lose weight.
Where do you find that calculator?
It's online.
Is that an actual calculator?
Yeah, you just Google it.
And I use plenty of that too.
Yeah, and it just says, put in your gender, put in--
I saw it in the book,
but I'd never heard of that before.
Yeah, it's the most accurate tool that I know of
and having talked to lots of other people
and written a few other books,
it's always something that I referenced
because, yeah, you put in your gender age, height, weight,
and then you're very specific about your activity level.
I train five days a week
with weight training for 60 minutes at a time
with this level of intensity.
And it says, okay, based on all these factors,
you're six foot tall, 220 pound,
male who's 41 and active five days a week for an hour
plus dog walks or whatever,
you're gonna be burning 3,124 calories every day.
So, what do I do with that information?
Well, then I can use my fitness power chronometer
or some other platform
to document my actual calorie intake,
at least for a few days,
to kinda see where I'm at
and say, okay, Robert,
you need to consume 3,124 calories just to maintain weight.
You wanna put on a little mass?
Okay, let's go 3,500 calories or more.
Closer to 3,500, 4,000.
And over time, adaptation kicks in
combined with resistance weight training.
So, over a course of a week or two weeks,
three weeks, four weeks, months down the road,
a year from now,
that's how you put on mass.
That's how you lose weight.
You have to be in either a calorie surplus or deficit
and be aware of it
and be supporting that with an exercise program
that's conducive to that result.
Nobody gains weight overnight.
Nobody loses weight overnight.
It's deliberate actions every single day
in either a surplus or deficit.
It doesn't just mean eat more or eat less.
It can also mean exercise more.
If I wanna lean out a little bit
like coming on the Rich Roll Podcast,
I get on the StairMaster for 45 minutes.
I can still eat the same,
but now I've burned a lot more calories, right,
than I was before.
So, really, to try to briefly
or succinctly answer your question,
I understand the calories that I need to consume every day
and then I eat those specific foods.
So, like I mentioned,
a breakfast could be like an oatmeal
with berries and walnuts.
I'm a big fan of fruit,
where I might eat a few bananas at a time for breakfast.
I stay hydrated.
Our bodies are mostly water.
That's important, especially kind of
the bigger or more active you are,
you've just gotta keep the water intake high.
And then I eat my favorite foods.
Like I mentioned, potatoes being a huge one.
And those could be mashed potatoes,
they could be fries,
they could be big, they could be in any capacity.
And then my favorite food really is a burrito bowl.
And so, that's why I have those batch
rice and beans and all that
that I can add avocado, tomato, lettuce,
salsas, mushrooms, peppers, and just heat it up
and I could do this every day.
And then I like the international cuisine
for dinner or post-workout
and I'm very fortunate.
My wife, Karen, makes incredible food
and is very generous.
She makes a lot of our meals.
She knows I lack a lot of skill in the kitchen
and sometimes I lack the discipline as well,
where my mind or my time is spent elsewhere.
And so, I'm very fortunate to have a wife
who helps helps me in that capacity.
You're 41 now?
How old are you, 41.
So, have you noticed any changes in your metabolism
or the way that your body kind of responds
to the training or the food that you're eating?
Yeah.
(laughs lightly)
I wish I didn't have to admit it.
I have a reason I'm going here, but, yeah, tell me.
I wish I didn't have to admit it,
but I was actually telling my wife that
right before I flew out here.
I'm like, man, I had it in my head
because I knew there'd be like videos and photos
that I'm gonna be ripped on the Rich Roll Podcast.
(laughs)
You're too in your head, dude.
You look great.
And I worked hard,
but I was also at the same time
trying to maintain this 220 pound body frame,
which obviously has some body fat on it too
and I was using the StairMaster
and I was doing fasted, cardio,
all the stuff I used to do in my 20's and 30's,
and I wasn't seeing the results quite as fast.
And I feel like there's a couple of factors at play.
One, stress and anxiety, which I suffer a lot from,
including coming on the show.
It was weeks of worry.
(chuckles)
Oh, come on.
And that, man, is the truth.
That's just the truth.
And so, that impacts me a little bit.
And then working with Vegan Strong,
is a nonprofit that I'm part of
and launching a book that we hope becomes the best seller,
it's time consuming
and then taking care of two dogs
and making sure I hang out with my wife
and make sure I'm social in some capacity,
the discipline has been there.
I'm still getting a lot of good exercise in,
but sometimes the results
have been a little bit slower recently, it feels like,
but at the same time,
if I get in the right lighting,
I take my little photos you see on Instagram
with me in the mirror
and I'm the biggest.
I've seen them.
Yeah, there's some of the best shape I've ever been in.
Everybody's has seen them.
What's that?
Everybody's seen them.
Yeah.
That's Robert Cheeke.
That's your thing, dude.
And I'm surprise you even wear a tank top.
Yeah, that's me and my smiling thumbs up
and the side pose,
but obviously I'm playing to my strengths.
I've focused on the muscle groups that look the best.
It's all part of this ego thing
that Matt and I talked about for an hour and a half
at dinner last night
is trying to overcome and let go of some of those things
of who we were a decade ago versus who we are now
and where we are within the movement 10 years ago,
compared to where we are now
and that wrestling match.
Yeah, no, I relate to that a lot.
Coming up on 55 pretty quick here
and one of the things that I've done during quarantine
is something that I haven't done in a very long time,
which is to focus on strength.
And I got back into the gym
and I have no problem putting on mass.
It happens (snaps) like that for me,
like almost too quickly,
but I was bulking up
and then I just didn't like how...
I felt good.
I felt strong,
but I just felt bulky
and I've kind of backed off a little bit.
It's fine if I pair that with some pretty decent volume
in terms of my endurance training
'cause I can maintain being lean,
but I'm not able to train that much right now
because of all the things that I have going on right now.
And so, I've kind of pivoted back
towards the running and the cycling and things like that
'cause I just felt like I was starting to feel
like the Michelin man a little bit.
So, I guess what I'm saying is that
I noticed that I can't shift gears in the way that I could
maybe 10 years ago
in terms of oh, I wanna put bulk on
and then I wanna lean out.
I can still do all those things,
but I need to bank more time in order to achieve those goals
versus the way that it was maybe a decade ago.
I've noticed exactly,
with the quarantine period,
like a lot of people, I did all kinds of cooking.
It was crazy.
I had so much fun with all that extra family time,
but just started eating junk food
and I kept telling myself,
well, I eat a vegan diet.
So, it's not really a problem.
I can't gain weight
and I'm always said
I don't really put on mass or get fat or anything,
but I had turned 40 a couple months ago
and it's just a little bit different now
and a lot of things are different.
I don't sleep like I used to.
I've had to get the blackout curtains
and get the little thing
where it cools your mattress at night
so that you don't wake up.
I'm sorry to do like wacky sleep.
Yeah, me too.
All the things that just came easy naturally
now you gotta work for them.
Exactly, so now I'm like,
well, I don't wanna eat a meal too close to bedtime
'cause that'll mess up my sleep
and partly because now I'm paying attention to the data,
which drives me nuts.
You got the Oura ring on you?
Yeah, I got it.
I need this data.
I can't lose this hour.
But then the data can with your head.
Oh, my gosh.
It really can.
I think it's a good thing,
but I think we haven't quite figured out
how to best live with it yet.
Anyway, I just think, yeah,
the changes are a little bit slower to happen.
But for me it's kind of a reason to get back into it
'cause it's like suddenly I can't just go on autopilot
and say, well I eat vegan.
So, I don't need to think about it.
And I was falling into that for awhile.
And then I actually did some heart health numbers
and they weren't all that good
'cause I've been in the Impossible Burgers
with all the soccer driving
and whatever else, just potato chips and just things
and I just kept telling myself, well, it's vegan.
So, I'll be fine
'cause I'm the vegan, healthy guy.
But seeing that, and it's not like they were scary numbers,
but it was like,
wow, this is not a trajectory I wanna keep going down.
So, it's been a really big boost for me
to say, wow, I'm 40 now.
It's a little bit different era for me.
And when I hit 50,
it'd be really cool
if I was in totally great control of this stuff.
So, I really got reinvigorated in the past few months
before all this stuff.
Let's talk a little bit about advocacy.
(sighs)
We alluded earlier
to sort of some infighting and the vegan movement.
There's a lot of sniping going on
and I spent a lot of time thinking about
how to be an advocate for the things that I believe in
and things that I care about.
And if you take
the Plant-based Athlete Movement as an example,
you'll see a spectrum of different strategies
from the super hardcore animal rights advocate
who is taking new prisoners
to the very gentle approach, Matt,
that I think you've adopted
and that is kind of in tune with your constitution.
It just feels very authentic to you.
If I had to say,
I'm more in your kind of side of that spectrum.
And I tend to think of it
as just trying to be an optimal living example
of the values and the ideals
that I care about
but I think it is really important
to be mindful about how we communicate these values.
To do it in a way that it connects and resonates
with as many people as possible.
So, Robert, how do you think about that?
It almost sounds cliche,
but I like the expression
that I'm in constant pursuit of the best version of myself,
but that's true.
That really is true
because I got into this
because I wanted to make a difference
in the world around me.
I wanted to make a difference to the farm animals
that I was around
and later I wanted to inspire people.
I really truly wanted and want to make a difference.
And whether that's because it makes me feel significant
or it makes me feel fulfilled
or that my life has purpose
because I'm significant in the life of somebody else,
even someone who just read a book and said,
"My life changed because of that."
That means something to me.
And I don't know if that's a selfish thing or an ego thing,
but that's how I conduct myself.
Whereas in my 20's,
it was more about,
I'm the new Tiger Woods of the vegan bodybuilding world.
I'm the best thing that's come to this movement
kind of thing.
You got driven
versus mission driven.
Yeah, but that was also the time.
I was in my 20's.
I think we've all gone through some of these phases,
where I wanted the magazine covers,
I wanted the TV stuff,
I wanted the newspapers,
I wanted the microphone.
And now I realize that there's so many messengers out there.
And so, elevating all of these other athletes
who are just in many cases,
better representatives as athletes.
They perform better in their sport.
They have better results.
Whether they have a smaller audience or bigger audience,
but just giving them an amplified platform
to just showcase what they're doing
is something that really means a lot to me now
in my advocacy.
I've never been one.
I've participated in protests and stuff,
but I'm not good at it.
This is not my personality.
Confrontational stuff is...
I know some people, I wish I were more like that,
including my wife,
I wish I was just more assertive in those kinds of things,
but I'm just not.
I'm not and I'm much more of what can I do?
What's the best use of my time to create the most change?
And that's where writing came from.
That's why I wanted a book like this.
It took a lot of manifesting, so to speak,
to get a hard cover book like this.
To self published books for a decade
and be on this pursuit since I was in third grade
and said someday I'm gonna be an author.
That's a platform for me.
I think I'm a better writer than I am a speaker.
I'm better at that than I am
at talking about animal rights.
Even if I feel it inside,
I'm not as great as a communicator,
as others who can just articulate
their thoughts and feelings better.
Right, I do watch those Earthling Ed videos
and it looks like he just naturally
is able to just pontificate
in the most eloquent way on these issues.
Yeah, and there's Joey Carbstrong
and plenty of other people.
That's their strength.
And so, what I've tried to use as my experience,
how many people have been a plant-based athlete
for a quarter century
and along that journey have gained 100 pounds
and have been able to have all these different experiences,
'cause that's one of the arguments
against the plant-based diet.
Oh, you'll do it for a year or two and then you'll fail
or there's no longevity in this
or show me someone who's been doing it for 20 years.
Well, hi, I'm here.
Or he put on all his mass
when he was eating animal products.
Yeah, it's not the case.
That frame was already there
from a lifetime of eating animal products.
Absolutely not the case.
There's so many shots
that get fired over that kind of thing.
And so, I figured
there's something maybe unique about that experience
and I can share that.
And then with this new book,
it was an opportunity to share all those other stories
from people you haven't heard of.
Caitlin Cook or Orla Walsh or Sharon Fichman
or Jehina Malik, who's been vegan since birth
and is a professional bodybuilder on the highest level,
the IFBB Pro.
And she, along with her other siblings, four other siblings,
went vegans since birth
and be able to tell those stories,
that is part of my advocacy is I'm a storyteller
and I like it.
I just embrace that.
That whether it's through audio like this
or video and or writing,
that's how I communicate a message is through stories
and I've got my own
and everyone has their own story to share.
And if I can help other people share their stories,
then that's where I feel like I've contributed
to the movement.
Yeah, I would agree with that.
I think both you guys
and Matt, everything that you've done with No Meat Athlete,
when I go to the site,
and I didn't say this at the outset,
but I've been visiting your website from the beginning.
When I was learning and you were starting
and I would go
and you'd have these very helpful blog posts
that I'm sure from the early days
still get traffic, right?
Oh, yeah.
They're just like, how do I start?
You know what I mean?
Those things are evergreen content,
but you've mastered meeting people where they're at, right?
It's this welcome, Matt.
Hey, everybody, come on in.
Let me hold your hand.
Let me guide you through this.
This is a judgment free space.
We're this beautiful community.
Yeah, it was the only way I could imagine doing it.
The opposite of that
is what repelled me for a long time
and finally I said I'm gonna do this no matter what
and I said I wanna be the opposite
of this sort of force that made it seem like
this scary, weird fringe thing.
I just wanted it to be cool.
You're not gonna be judged if you're not perfect yet.
It's fine.
I don't know.
That's been my thing.
Like Robert said,
being an example of that,
that wasn't really the intention
but I realized once I qualified for Boston
and then got into the 50, 100 mile races,
people started viewing me as that.
And then I started saying,
okay, well, I can be that as well,
but I'm not gonna tell anyone ever
that this is what you should do,
because I don't know what you should do.
You know that.
Your site and everything that you do
isn't this cult of personality around you.
It's about the community.
No, it's absolutely not.
For awhile, it got to be about me
when I was doing those races
and I think I got mixed up in my head.
I was like what it was about a little bit
but then once I ran my 100 mile there,
my motivation for running just disappeared.
I just lost it.
Boston and then that and I was like,
I don't have any reason to go do it.
It's not like I need to prove to myself.
Right, it wasn't like I had mastered that by any means.
I think I ran 28 or 29 hours.
It wasn't a fast 100.
I could have certainly done much had I set new goals
but for whatever reason,
I had done this thing that I thought was impossible
and then my motivation just went away when that went.
So, once that happened, I realized I was like, wow.
I can't really be an example right now
at this stage in my life.
So, I need to sort of step aside
and find other writers.
And then at the same time,
I got into the entrepreneurship side of it
and said what other businesses can I go to?
And I met a partner named Matt Tolman,
who's just really kind of helped us reach new levels
and it's been awesome the past few years
with what we've done
and we've reached so many more people now
with that new approach.
But I guess as I realized that it is not at all about me,
and I've also gone through this thing now
where I'm starting to make my way back
into fitness and health
and putting it in the very front of my mind,
not just for my kids, but actually for me again.
I'm starting to kind of come back
and do more writing and stuff like that.
So, it feels very good now
to come at it now as an example, I hope,
of someone who's just really thriving
and doing great in this sort of next phase.
I'm not gonna be setting PRS,
because this is not on my...
I'm sure it could,
but it's just not something I wanna be doing.
Well, I appreciate the honesty and the transparency there.
I think it's important
to be intellectually honest and rigorous
about what we know and what we don't know
and I don't like how certain people
who are part of this movement kind of overstate the case
'cause I don't think it's in service of the broader movement
because you're basically exposing yourself
to be criticized or attacked
because you feel so strongly
or have such an attachment
or perhaps you're coming from an animal ethics perspective.
This proneness to overstate
the health implications of this diet, I think,
causes more problems than benefits.
And I found the scientific analysis in the book
to be just that in the sense that it is rigorous,
you're not making claims that are unsubstantiated.
You're quick to point out we still need more research here,
or this is what we don't know
and I really think
that that is the way forward
if you wanna really advocate for this
in a sustainable, substantive way.
And we knew that was the approach we wanted to take.
And especially we had our eyes on Dr. Michael Greger
to write the forward for a long time.
He's been a big inspiration to both of us.
And so, we knew it had to be evidence-based
and then having the opportunity to talk with dozens,
either in person or through email,
dozens of experts, registered dieticians, doctors,
many of the people we both know and love.
Brenda Davis, Dr. Klaper.
So many others, Campbell Esselstyn.
It felt like that was the right approach to take
with this book,
especially because so many of our other books
have been kind of memoir type approach
or my philosophy, which is kind of unsubstantiated.
It's just what worked for me.
(laughs)
Who cares?
Here's how I built 100 pounds.
But this was a different approach,
more like grown up approach
that this is our kind of a return
for both of us in kind of a way,
where we took a little bit of time,
whether it was with our families or taking a back seat
from the blogs being about us or the websites being about us
and having that time to reflect
and watch how the movement has grown
over the past decade, especially,
and then come together as long-time friends
with really this endurance platform, strength platform,
and two people who've built
these relatively popular websites
and said let's merge here
and tell a really compelling story
'cause the plant-based movement is ready for it.
It's ready for this kind of story.
In canvassing all the research that went into the book,
the scientific evidence-based research
on plant-based diet efficacy in terms of being an athlete,
obviously, there's some gaps.
Is there a study that
when you're doing all this,
was there ever a moment where you're like,
why isn't there a study about this?
Here's what I really would like to know.
Why hasn't anybody done that study?
Yeah, and I've actually talked to Colin Campbell
directly about that.
It was based on some of my own experiences.
So, Dr. Campbell,
why is this working for me on a low protein diet
to be the biggest and strongest
and even in the best photos,
if you wanna say aesthetically, that I've ever been?
Can we get people to do this?
Do a low protein muscle building--
When you say low protein,
you're not really meaning,
you just mean adequate.
Meal in a day, yeah.
So, I'm talking like 10% of my calorie intake
is from protein, somewhere around 90 grams.
Which actually isn't low.
It's just actually where you're supposed to be.
It's a little in comparison--
Well, in comparison to the culture.
To the culture, the bodybuilding,
the muscle building culture.
It's lower as a percentage.
Many people consume 20, 30, 40%
of their calories in protein
as bodybuilders and weightlifters.
It's a low as a total number of grams.
Many people consume 200, 300 grams of protein,
myself included 10 years ago,
and I'm doing 90, 75, 78 grams a day
and maintaining a massive 200 plus pounds
and close to 220.
So, I talked to Colin Campbell about that
and I'm so intrigued by it
because I've experienced it firsthand.
And I feel like it's...
I know I'm not special.
It's not that, oh, Robert's got this great work ethic.
We already know that's already been exposed
that sometimes I just don't have it
and I'd rather do other things
or I've gotta write a book
or I'm interested in a basketball game.
I'm not always super, super consistent.
So, why is that working for me
compared to when I was younger,
had greater levels of testosterone,
had more ambition, more enthusiasm,
more passion for competitive bodybuilding.
I was a super fan
going to all the Olympia and all the shows.
But why now later in my life,
when I lift recreationally, casually for the enjoyment of it
and I'm bigger, stronger,
and in many cases, let's say, look better aesthetically
on a low protein diet without protein supplementation?
How does that work from a nutritional standpoint?
And I'd like to see some of that.
So, you went to him and asked him that?
What did he say?
There's no study.
He's all about data and research.
Well, we don't know.
Right.
We don't know.
And I (chuckles) even said, 'cause I don't know--
Well, Garth Davis would be another candidate.
Well, he's not a research scientist,
but somebody who could perhaps spearhead
or create a situation
in which a study like that could be conducted.
I was even saying,
because I don't know how a lot of this stuff works,
the actual scientific study.
I said, "Can we do something here, Dr. Campbell?"
(laughs)
He's enthusiastic.
He obviously has endorsed really all of my work
and he knows that I came to this conclusion
based on his program from the Center for Nutrition Studies.
He knows why I adopted a low protein diet
or what we can call an adequate protein diet, I guess.
But I would love to participate in something
if it were available, but I don't know.
And I don't know how many people are willing to do that.
So, basically, the way you would style it
is you'd get a group of people
and you'd put them in the gym.
You'd separate them.
You'd put them on strict diets.
One with a higher protein
and the other on more of your protocol,
and then just calibrate their gains over a 30 day period
or something like that, right?
You'd have to control--
I think that kind of thing has happened somewhere, right,
with the plant protein
versus animal protein studies of people.
Right, but it's always unclear
what exactly did these people eat?
Yeah, that's true.
Controlling the variables is--
And they're also going for that threshold
of we wanna maximize the 1.6 grams of protein per kilogram,
for true muscle building.
And so, it's still on the higher end of protein intake,
even if it's plant versus animal protein,
including the most recent study we referenced in the book.
So, that's what I'm saying.
I'd like to see on the lower protein side
and just see how it works.
The calories can be the same,
but get more complex carbohydrates in there,
or a few more fats in there
from these really nutrient dense sources
and let's see what the real difference is,
because I feel like it's something I experienced for myself.
I talked to Niemeyer about it,
and he was intrigued and started to apply some of that
for himself as well.
And I feel like maybe that could be the next frontier
in plant-based athleticism,
just shifting our focus more
on complex carbohydrates versus protein obsession.
Yeah.
Do you think that's what it'll take, though,
for the mainstream athletes
to really adopt this,
where it's like that's now the standard diet,
or do you think it's just gonna take one superstar
and someone's gonna follow it
and then suddenly it will be the booming thing?
It's like that whole industry versus academia thing.
Maybe in theory, this is gonna be better,
but until we see that everyone's doing it,
because it's the gold standard now for nutrition
and it's the way
to get paid the most, honestly, in your sports
on this mainstream level.
I don't know.
But we're seeing so many
begin to be sprinkled in all the different sports
that are doing that.
I think that's not far off from happening.
Yeah, I think it's both.
I think that's a great question.
I think it's a bottom-up and top-down situation, right?
From, the bottom up perspective,
you need this groundswell movement of people
who are inspired by the books
and the YouTube videos and the podcasts
to give it a try in their own daily lives
and then you need the superstar athlete
who ends up doing it and crushes it
in a way that defies all the kind of poo-poos who say,
"Oh, well that person's a freak of nature,"
or "It's a one-off," or "This is an outlier,"
or "They were already great before."
You're gonna need a critical mass
of really elite, high performance athletes
across a diversity of sports, I think,
before you get to a cultural tipping point.
We're moving towards that,
but right now when you canvas like professional sports
and you have a bunch of these people in the book,
but we haven't reached critical mass if we're being honest.
There's a couple people here and there.
(laughs)
And to be fair,
it's a lot to ask
if you're getting paid millions of dollars a year
and your entire life is premised upon you performing
at the highest level in your given sport
to say, hey, I want you to throw out
everything you ever thought you knew about nutrition
and try this other thing.
The risk analysis doesn't make sense
for that person to roll the dice
until there's enough people that create that critical mass
and a feeling of security
in starting to segue into that direction.
And that may never happen.
I'm kind of glad we came back to this
and that you mentioned not overstating the point in there
because I only realized just this past week
as I was reading the book more and thinking more about it,
that this isn't really about,
at least, I don't think for me or Robert,
it's not about convincing top athletes
that this is the way to get better at your sport,
because we don't know that.
I think the hypothesis here, the premise
is that this is a viable alternative to the other diets now.
Maybe the steady state we're gonna reach
is that in pro sports, there's the paleo, the keto,
I don't know about keto,
(chuckles)
but there's the paleo, there's the vegans or plant-based
and it's not that one dominates
because maybe all these work
for short-term sports performance,
short-term meaning 5, 10, 15 years.
I think this one, the plant-based one,
is the one that's gonna make those people
way happier and healthier
after their careers are over.
But I don't know.
But I wonder if that's okay.
No, I would state it a little bit more
stridently than that
to say that not only is it a viable alternative,
I think there are advantages to it
that outweigh other protocols,
particularly for athletes
who are approaching the twilight of their career.
When you look at Tom Brady,
now, Tom Brady is never gonna say
that he's a plant-based athlete or that he's a vegan
and he's not, technically,
but the guy eats a very plant forward diet
for the most part.
There's some animal products in there,
but the guy's essentially eating a "plant-based diet."
He's crushing it in a way
that no other athlete in his position ever has.
People are paying attention.
He gets made fun of for it at the same time,
but you cannot deny the incredible results
that this guy's getting.
So, when you're in that twilight space
and you're starting to get injured more
and you just can't get out of bed
in the way that you used to,
I think there's a receptivity to this way of eating.
Those people are suddenly looking for that extra edge
and a way to extend their career another season or two.
And I think those are the people
that are the ones who are jumping on board here
and I think it builds from there.
And you know who embodies that
more than anyone to me right now
is Chris Paul.
Chris Paul--
Right, that's a good point.
I just had a chance to just meet him briefly,
talk briefly with him in person
but he said those exact things.
You look at his quotes
and he talked about
how he adopted a plant-based diet
and within a short amount of time,
a couple of months into it,
where's the pain and stiffness
I used to have in the morning when you would wake up?
And you look at his career,
he was an amazing player
and then was off the All-Star team
for two or three seasons in a row,
adopted a plant-based diet, talks about it enthusiastically,
returned as an All-Star every season since,
every team he's got on has gotten better.
He's nearly an MVP candidate this year.
He's probably in the top 10.
And he talks about this renaissance career
that he's having.
He brought his athleticism back.
He got his first dunk.
It sounds silly, but he's a smaller guy,
maybe a little bit taller than me.
He got his first dunk ever in a game.
It was this two-handed alley-oop dunk from Russell Westbrook
in the All-Star game.
It was awesome.
It was a highlight for me.
One more proof do we need, right?
(laughs)
But really he's a prominent NBA basketball player.
And the fact that JaVale McGee met him briefly also
and won a championship last year.
Won as a major player on the Lakers
and has been plant-based for years now.
and DeAndre Jordan.
And there was a time
in one of the early editions of this book,
where one third of the entire Brooklyn Nets team
was plant-based.
Now some of those guys got traded.
Wilson Chandler's no longer there,
Garrett Temple is no longer there,
Kyrie I hope is still 100%
although I'm not quite sure he's 100% vegan now.
The Redskins had a thing going on for a while, too.
They did, 2017
and the Titans did around the same time, 2017, as well
with Derek Morgan
and, of course, Erin Foster and early Tony Gonzalez.
Yeah, Erin Foster he's retired,
but also he kind of moved away from it.
But he did it exclusively for what a while.
He was in touch with Forks Over Knives on a regular basis
and he was the number one running back that season
in numerous categories,
including rushing attempts and touchdowns,
something like that.
Chris Paul is a great example of these twilight years.
He's playing his best basketball ever later in his career.
Serena Williams is another one who's just dominant.
Zdeno Chara in the place with the Bruins he's crushing it.
I don't actually know it.
Yeah, you gotta get on this guy.
I think I heard about him from the Game Changers.
I followed them on Instagram, but just--
He's killing it.
There's so many athletes out there now doing it.
Messi during the season.
Lionel Messi is apparently vegan.
I haven't confirmed this
but that's what appears to be.
And he's kind of on the down slope of his career.
So, it's great but--
Lewis Hamilton.
Alex Morgan, Novak Djokovich.
There's a lot there.
There's a lot of great athletes.
We mentioned a bunch of them
and even some who maybe are not doing it now,
like Mike Tyson but, again, I talk with him in person.
He was doing it for years
and he got so many benefits from it.
He lost a whole bunch of weight and felt all this stuff
and then I think he kind of crept back into
now making my comeback,
fighting for millions of dollars,
basically, for charity now
and he went back to some of that desire
for animal protein or something,
but he was in vegan campaigns for years
and he credits a lot of that
to his health resurgence from a plant-based diet
and many elite athletes have
and we're hoping,
yeah, we're certainly not there.
We're not at some sort of tipping point or critical mass.
We wish we had more names to add in this book.
Sure. But I think if you go back 15 years
and had to guess where the culture would be
and now where it is right now,
I think we've exceeded any expectation that any of us had
in terms of adoption.
Absolutely, no question about it.
Yep.
I wanna round this out with one last thread,
which is another thing you talk about in the book
and I think it's really important
and something that I know
a lot of people who are playing around with
this lifestyle contend with,
which is dealing with an unreceptive,
(chuckles) social circle.
We talked about it in the context of your kids
but a lot of people,
I think we underestimate the impact
of just navigating people in our lives,
in terms of the impact that that has
on the lifestyle choices that we make.
Just look, it's healthy, just do it.
But then when you're at the dinner party
or you gotta go do this thing,
it's just easier to go along to get along
and it's harder to say,
"No, I'm doing this for myself
and I'm carving out and this is who I am."
So, you mean standing up for yourself,
not trying to push it on--
Right, how do you kind of remain true to your own values
and also manage the naysayers in your life
or the people that are kind of trying to talk you
out of doing this thing
that you wanna explore for yourself?
I think it depends so much on the person, of course.
For me, if I was going to a dinner party,
the last thing on my mind
would be the idea
that maybe I could convert someone here into this.
Yeah, no, I'm not talking about that.
I'm just talking about feeling comfortable
in your own skin.
Sure, but I'm only making the point
that that's where I started
with saying, I'm not gonna be doing that,
'cause some people do say as soon as they go vegan
that they wanna tell everyone
and show their family or whatever
that they also shall do this.
Just life tip that doesn't work out--
No, it doesn't,
but people still think
it's right.
Stop doing that.
Right, so, I started there.
Like everything else, openness.
Don't show up at the party and say,
"Hey, by the way,
"I'm trying to eat this plant-based diet.
"I'm not gonna eat what you're making,"
but communicating in advance, obviously,
eating ahead of time,
which I think is kind of common sense,
but I just never expected anyone to cater to me.
I was never gonna show up and say,
"Hey, this is what I'm doing now.
"I expect that there was gonna be this stuff there for me."
You need to re-align
everything you're doing to meet my...
(laughs)
And so, that combined with a healthy amount
of being willing to laugh at it,
'cause my uncle would at one point,
pretty early in me being vegetarian,
not yet vegan, I don't think,
at a big 4th of July thing,
the whole family was there.
There was probably 30 people there.
And he brought out some lettuce on a plate.
Everyone's was eating crabs
and he said,
"Hey Matt,
"here's your dinner."
"This is for you, Matt."
Yeah, of course.
And, I guess, a different person might get upset
and make it a big scene or something but I just laughed.
I don't know what else to do.
I'm not gonna win that situation, I don't think
and I personally think,
and I know people disagree with me on this,
but I think by laughing there,
you really kinda break the pattern
of someone expecting you to get offended
and expecting that their joke's
gonna really have a big impact on you.
And if instead you can also kind of laugh
or like make some other joke that just goes to their level--
I would just double down.
Go way overboard in terms of how happy you are
that he went out of his way
to give you the piece of lettuce.
(chuckles)
Yeah, and I think that disarms people.
I think that makes them say,
"Hey, wait a minute.
"Maybe not all of them are these militant people
"who are out to change."
And then, of course,
if you're also happening to drop 30 pounds
or happening to start training for a half marathon,
whether or not that's actually what your diet
has caused you to do,
but if it's just that's your method of saying,
hey, I'm gonna demonstrate
that this is a good way to eat
or that this is working for me.
I'm gonna do this,
even if it's, like I said,
if it's unrelated to the effect your diet is having on you,
I think, again, it just comes back
to that being an example thing
that I think that's the most powerful thing you can do
to make people see it as legitimate for you
and then also probably in the back of their minds
are considering should they also do it?
And for me, I never forget
why I got into this in the first place.
That always compels me.
So, I'm not going to make sacrifices
or fall into some sort of trap,
where I'm tempted to consume this or that
because that's the only thing available
and I've been flying from here to Australia for 17 hours
and I'm hungry or whatever the case is.
I just always remember why I came to a plant-based diet
or vegan lifestyle.
And that really compels me in all the actions that I do.
So like Matt, I also kind of laugh things off.
I'm not combative with people
because I realized that's what they're trying
to get out of me,
including places like...
Some of the awful places of the world are the internet.
Twitter is a pretty awful place.
YouTube comments maybe the worst place on the internet,
I'm not sure, but so I've heard.
I just woke up to...
Here I am, enthusiastic,
I'm here to do the Rich Roll Podcast,
I'm hanging out with Matt,
our book is coming out
and I realized that I'm in some sort of Twitter thread
that someone volunteered me to be part of.
It was like, Robert's an example
of how you can be big and strong
and they're just kind of fighting an argument,
but using me as their ammo.
And so, now all the comments are negative about me,
(laughs)
but I can't let that bother me and I don't engage them.
I just ignore all of that stuff.
And that's what I do.
I learned a long time ago from Dale Carnegie,
the best way to win an argument is to avoid one.
And that doesn't mean that it's taken a step back
for activism or anything like that.
It's not how I see it,
but I see it that the people who are trying
to do these deliberate acts
or deliberate attacks or deliberately make fun of,
I don't allow that to be an argument that I participate in,
but in a more practical sense, what you're talking about,
I'm actually dealing with right now.
My wife and I recently moved to Fort Collins, Colorado
about a year ago
and we've had this pandemic going on.
So, just now neighbors are starting to say,
"Hey, come on over for some beers and barbecue,"
and all this stuff
and I'm trying to figure out how to tell them
that maybe that won't work for me,
but we're getting a grill
and we have all the Beyond Burgers
and all that kind of stuff
and we're gonna kind of show them our stuff--
Well, you should invite them over to your house first
for "Hey, we're throwing a vegan barbecue,"
and you'll be the hit of the neighborhood.
Everyone will love you.
(laughs)
And what's funny is they already know about my book
because I can't stop talking about it, of course.
They all know I have this book out.
You've gotta check on Amazon
and I'm wearing vegan on my shirt
and like, "Yeah, come on over for a barbecue and beer."
They haven't made that connection yet
that this plant-based--
It's not their job to make the connection, Robert.
Right.
You can go over there
and when they offer you a burger you say, "No, thanks."
You don't have to say anything more than that.
You just be like, "I'm good with this," or whatever.
Right, it's just a new environment for me,
because I've always been known as kind of the vegan guy,
whether it's in my family circle, relatives,
in-laws, holidays.
That's been part of my identity since I was a kid.
I'm the vegan guy.
So, I've just dealt with that.
People knowing that,
but now in a new city, new neighbors, new environment,
I kind of have to show people, I guess,
who I am or--
I could see you're literally struggling
in real time with this,
but I think that's the relatable thing.
That was the reason for the question,
because I think people who are trying to make this switch
have a lot of trepidation
about how they're gonna deal with their neighbors
or their friends or their relatives.
You've been living this for a very long time,
but you've been doing it in a situation
in which everybody's briefed on who you are,
but now you're standing in the shoes of the newcomer,
so to speak,
who's trying to figure out how to be gracious and graceful
while still adhering to this thing that's important to you.
Yeah, and it is a little bit new.
It just happened recently on Easter.
I went down,
my brother lives about an hour away
with his wife and two kids
and they had some gathering there
where a few neighbors came over
and one of the neighbors was so nice.
He was just so friendly.
He brought over some cinnamon rolls
and he just really was insisting that we have them.
Eventually, my brother came out and said,
"Oh, Robert's vegan.
"He's gonna have to pass."
But that was kind of a new territory for me
to have to politely decline.
I don't have kids.
I'm not used to family gatherings or those kinds of things.
Kids' parties, or Easter egg hunting and all this.
I'm just not in those situations.
I wasn't gonna eat it and I'm not tempted to,
I was gonna come up with some sort of excuse or explanation
or "I already ate.
"I'm good,"
but I'm going through some of that stuff now
and I don't know, it's like I'm new again.
It's just adorable
how you're getting all uncomfortable now
because this is the dilemma
that anybody who's trying to do this experiences
and you've been doing it for 25 years
and you're out of your depth all of a sudden
and it's funny.
Yeah.
(laughs)
It's a new adventure.
And also I'm not always plastering vegan on all my shirts.
My wife tells me to wear something
other than that these days after.
(laughs)
I'm just always wearing that message everywhere I go.
That's funny.
Well, good, you guys.
I think we did it.
How do you feel?
I feel great.
This is awesome.
This is pretty cool, man.
I love you guys.
I think this book is tremendous.
It's quite an accomplishment.
You guys should be very proud
and I really think
that it's a go-to one-stop shop
to answer every question you would ever have
about how to crush it as a plant-based athlete.
You go deep into all the micronutrients and macronutrients
and how to make it work
depending upon whether you're trying to be fast and strong
or go all day.
It's all in there.
You got recipes
and you even have a light sprinkling
of a self-help fairy dust in there for everybody, right?
You guys should be super proud.
Thank you.
I'm proud of you guys.
I can't wait for everybody to enjoy the book.
It comes out June 15th?
June 15th.
The book is available.
It's available everywhere.
Robert's not used to the book being available anywhere
except in the trunk of his car.
(laughs)
So, this is new for him too.
That is.
I'm already going to my local Barnes & Noble
to introduce myself,
to like, "Hi?"
I'm sure you are.
I know you well enough to know, yeah.
I see a lot of that in your near future.
And that's what I'm already doing
because this is so new for me.
I don't see my books in stores.
I've been an author for 10 years and this is so exciting
and I wouldn't be here without Matt.
I wanna say that I wouldn't be here
without Matt as a co-author
to have a book on this scale
with a major publisher that's in stores everywhere.
And so, I wanna thank you for that, Matt.
Thank you, Robert.
And I wouldn't be able to do that
without all the people who actually trust me
and read my stuff.
So, thank you.
Awesome.
Thank you guys for having us on.
Yeah, absolutely.
Robert, it's your do, your do for this experience.
Thank you.
What you guys created is amazing.
So awesome, everybody pick it up.
In the meantime, you can track these guys down.
You can find Matt at @nomeatathlete.com.
What's the, just on Twitter and Instagram,
what's the best place for people to find you?
Yeah, veganbodybuilding.com
and veganstrong.com, kinda doing both these days.
Cool, and anywhere else people wanna talk to you?
lovecomplement.com is our supplement line,
which is a very mindful brain of supplements.
Cool.
If you wanna see silly flexing,
Instagram's the place to find me.
Yeah, right.
That's true.
And No Meat Athlete radio.
You're like Doug handles.
He's doing a lot of that also.
So, it's not always you there,
but people can check that out.
Like I said, it's not about me.
It's what Doug keep saying.
He's like, "You've scaled an enterprise
"beyond your personality."
That's something I need to learn how to do.
(laughs)
I don't know how to get it
but, anyway, awesome, you guys.
Best of luck.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I'm at your service.
Let me know how I can help
and you can come back and talk to me again sometime.
Thank you, Rich
We'd love to.
Peace.
Plants.
"Plant-based athlete."
(laughs)
(upbeat music)